QUITE A LOT.
THIS IS NOT GOOD.
.
LET'S GET STARTED.
WELCOMEO THE 366th HARVARD
COMMENCEMENT.
I'M DIANA ECK, AND I'M HERE IN A
BOOTH HIGH ABOVE THE
TERCENTENARY THEATER WITH DANIEL
SCHRAG, PROFESSOR OF THEOLOGY
D HEAD OF THE HARVARD
UNIVERSITY ACCEPT FOREFOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
DAN, THIS IS AN ENVIRONMENT WE
QUESTION, OKAY.
THE UMBRELLAS ARE GOING UP AND
ACTUALLY GIVG US SOME HE
THERE WOTE A SETTING DOWN
POUR.
IT IS NOT THE DAY WE HAD HOPED
FOR, BUT IT IS A DAY OF A GRATE
RITE OF PASSAGE FOR ALL THESE
UDENTS WHO ARE HERE WITH US.
>> DIANA, GETS GREAT TO BE HERE,
IT'S ACTUALLY IN SOME WAYS A
BEAUTIFUL DAY.
AS YOU RECALL, THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS HAVE BEEN BRUTALLY HOT.
WATCHING ALL THESE POOR STUDENTS
SWELTERING IN THEIR ROBES, AT
LET THEY'LL STAY COOL TODAY.
A LITTLE RAIN WILL NOT WASH THE
JOY AWAY FROM ALL THE PARENTS
AND ALL THE GRANDPARENTS WHO ARE
WATCHING THESE WONDERFUL
GRADUATES TODAY.
THIS IS REAY AN INCREDIBLE DAY
OF CELEBRATION, BOTH FOR HARVARD
AND FOR ALL OF THEIFFERENT
PEOPLE WHO HELPED THESE
SPECTACULAR STUDENTS GET TO THIS
POINT IN TIR CAREERS.
IT'S REALLY A VY SPECIAL TIME
>> IT IS WONDERFUL.
YOU SEELL OF THE PARENTS
SEATED BEHIND AND AROUND THE
ASSEMBLED GRADUATES, BUT THE
GRADUATES THEMSELVES BASICALLY
TAKE UP ALL OF THE TERCENTENARY
THEATER.
THEY ARE FROM EVERY ONE OF E
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS, THEY HAVE
BEEN MAKING THEIR ENTRY NOW INTO
THEIR RESPECTIVE PLACES INTO THE
TERCENTENARY THEATER FOR A FEW
TES.
THEYE GETTING THEIR SEATS, AND
THEN AT THE VERY END OF ALL
THESE PROCESSION, T
UNDERGRADUATES WILL ENTER INTO
THEIR SEATS.
AND THEN WE WILL HAVE REALLY THE
KINDF ASSEMBLAGE THAT IS WHAT
HARVARD UNIVERSITY MEANS.
THERE ARE VERY FEW TIMES, IN
FACT, NO ONE CAN REMEMBER WHEN
THE WORD HARVARD AS A WHOLE
INCLES ALL THE PEOPLE
>> IT IS SPECTACULAR TO SEE
EVERYBODY TOGETHER.
ONE OF E THINGS, DIANA, ABOUT
THIS CEREMONY, WHICH THE VIEWERS
ON TELEVISION DON'T SEE QUITE AS
OF THE UNDERGRADUATES LINING UP.
IT'S REALLY ONE OF THE GREAT
THINGS AS A FACULTY MEMBER YOU
PROCES THROUGH THE CROWD OF
UNDERGRADUATES.
SO YOU GET TO S ALL THE
STUDENTS WHO HAVE TAKEN THEIR
COURSES OVER THE YEARS, WHO HAVE
INTERACTED WITH YOU OR THE
YEARS, AND IT'S REALLY ONE OF
THE SPECIAL THINGS.
IT TAKES A LITTLE LONGER,
THEREFORE, FOR EVERYBODY TO COME
TAKE THEIR SEATS, BECAUSE THE
UNRGRADUATES ARE NOT YET IN
THE TERCENTENARY THEAR, BUT
IT'S A WONDERFUL TRADITION.
>> THE SHOTS THAT YOU SEE AS
HERE WE SEE SOME OF THE
GRADUATES WHO WILLPROCESS IN,
YOU WI SEE THE UNDGRADUATES
LINED UP AS WE DID JUST A MOMENT
AGO IN FRONT OF THE JOHN HARVARD
STATUTE AND ALL THE WAY THROUGH
THE OTHER PART OF HARVARD YARD,
WHICH IS THE FRESHMAN YARD.
AND TY OPE THEIR RANKS TO
CREATE A KIND OF PROCESSIONAL
AI FOR THE PRESIDENT'S
PROCESSION AND FOR THE FACULTY.
AND THAT WILL B THE SORT OF
CONCLUSION AS THE PRESIDENT'S
PROCESSION MOVES THROUGH T
OP RANKS OF THE
UNDERGRADUATES.
>> RIGHT.
YOU SEE THERE EVERYBODY
CHATTERING, EVERYBODY EXCITED,
WILL GET CALLED ON ONE THE AA
TIME, ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
STUDENTS FOR THE WIDE VARIETY OF
DEGREES THAT HARVARDOFFERS,
THEY'RE ALL HERE, THEY'RE ALL
EXCITED, IT'S REALLY A WONDERFUL
>> AND WE SEE BECAUSEHIS IS A
RITE OF PASSA SOO SPEAK, THE
PROCESSIONS HAVE A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE, THE GRADUATE
STUDENTS PROCESSING INTO THE
TERCENTENARY THEATE AND FROM
THE STANDPOINT OF THE
UNDERGRADUATES, I'M ONE OF THE
FACULTY DEANS OF LELL HOUSE,
SO WE HAVE I PROCESSION, AS A
TH HOUSES DO,AVE A VERY EARLY
BREAKFAST, ABOUT 6:30 IN THE
MORNING, TO THE SENIOR CHAPEL.
AND THE SENIOR CPEL IS SOR OF
THE VERSION OF THE DAILY MORNING
PRAYERS THAT TAKES PLACE HERE,
BUT A MUCH MORE ECUMENICAL,
RELIGIOUS VERSION.
THEY ARE CROWDED, THE WHOLE OF
SENIOR CLASS INTO SENIOR CHAPEL,
AND THEN TAKE THEIR PLACES IN
THIS -- THESE PROCESSIONAL
LINES.
AND SO THEY PROCESS BEHIND IN
THE CE OF LOWELL HOUSE, WE
CAMEEHIND OUR BAG PIPER, AND
IN BASE OF LOWEL HOUSE, THEY
CA
BAND.
THERE ARE MUSICAL FORCES THAT
GUIDE OUR STUDENTS INTO THE
TERCENTENARY THEATER ON THIS
WONDERFUL MORNIN
ONE OF THOSE GRADUATING SENIORS,
JUSTIN SZASZ IS HERE.
JUSTIN, WELCOME.
ARE YOU HAVING FUN THIS MORNING?
>> YEAH, IT'S GREAT TO BE
MOTHER.
>> WHERE DID YOU COME FROM THIS
MORNING?
WHERE IS YOUR HOUSE?
>> I'M FROM PFORZHEIMER HOUSE.
>> DID YOU HAVE SOME
PROCESSIONAL MUSIC THAT SAW YOU
HERE?
>> NOT TOO MUCH.
WE WENT TO THE CHURCH
>> THE CHAPEL.
>> AND WE HAVE A REALLY EX-LENT
SERVICE, WE SANG "FAIR HARVARD"
AT THE END, AND THEN WE WERE
WATCHING THE GRADUATED CLASSES
GO BY.
>> SO JUSTIN, YOU'RE A SOCIAL
STUDIES MAJOR.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> BUT I KNOW BECAUSE YOUOOK
MY COURSE LAST FALL, AS A
SENIOR, WHICH IS UNUSUAL TO TAKE
A GEN ED COURSE.
>> RIGHT.
SO I HAD DONE MOST OF MY AGAIN
EDUCATN REQUIREMENTS IN
EARLIER YEARS BUT HAD LEFT MY
SCIENCE REQUIREMENTS FOR LATER
YEARS, AND I REALLY WANT TO FIND
A SCIENCE CLASS THA WOULD GIVE
ME A REALLY USEFUL PIECE OF
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE WORLD, AND
MY FOCUS AREA IS MODERN MIDDLE
EAST, AND THERE HAVEEEN A LOT
OF TALK IN RECENT YEARS ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL EFFECTS BOTH IN
T
CLIMATE CHANGE ON THE MIDDLE
EA.
SOY THOHT THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC TO KNOW MORE
ABOUT.
>> THAT'S WONDERFUL.
>> IT SURE IS.
>> TELL US A LITTLE BIT AUT
YOUR SENIOR THESIS.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE CAUSE
THE SYRIAN CONFLICT.
>> RIGHT.
SO I'M TRACING THE ECONOMIC
ROOTS OF THE SYRIAN CIVIL WAR.
SO WHAT IID ON THE ONE HAND I
CONSTRUCTED FAIRLY COMPLEX
ECONOMIC STRUCTURE OF SYRIA, AND
THEN A COUPLE HUNDRED NEW
SOURCES TO RECONSTRUCT DAY BY
DAY EVENT BY EVENTHE FIRST TWO
WEEKS OF PROTESTS IN SYRIA AS
PART OF THE ARAB SPRING, WHERE
THOSE PROTESTS TOOK PLACE, WHO
WAS PROTESTING, HOW LARGE THE
PROTESTS WERE, WT THEY WERE
PROTESTING, AND THEN I CONNECTED
THE TWO.
WHAT I DISCOVERED, ESSENTIALLY,
WAS ABOUT 80 PERCENT OF THE
FIRST PROTESTS TOOK PLACE IN
LOCATIONS THAT WERE THE MOST
IMPOVERISHED LOCATIONS BEFORE
T
PROTESTERS WERE INTERESTED IN
PROTESTING ISSUES OF CORRUPTION,
IS OF MEMBERS OF THE
GOVERNMENT, MEMBERS OF THE
REGIME TAKING MOREHAN THEIR
FAIR SHAR
>> THAT'S VERY INTERESTING.
>> WHAT A WONDERFUL PROJECT.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THIS.
>> I'D LOVE TO SHARE IT.
>> THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
WORK TO ME
>> AFTER YOU GRAATE ARE YOU
THINKING OF TRAVELLING TO THE
MIDDLE EAST?
>> I AM.
HAVE BEGUN TO STUDY ARABIC,
BUT THINK I IMMEDIATE TO
BECOME FLUID AS ON AS
POSSIBLE,
THAT WOULD T TRAVEL TOUGH THE
REAMING.
MY FOCUS HAS BEEN SYRIA, WHICH
OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN'T GOO SYRIA
RIGHT NOW, BUT IF GO TO OTHER
COUNTRIES IN THE MIDDLE EAST,
THAT MIGHT OPEN UP NEW RESEARCH
OPPORTUNIES FOR OTHER
PROJECTS, IT WOU HELP ME
BECOME FLUID IN ARABIC.
>> CONGRATULATIONSES TO YOU.
>> WE'RE JUST SEEING NOW THE
WHOLE HARVARD CORPORATION
STARNG TO START THEIR
PROCESSION.
THERS NAN KEOHANE, A SPECIAL
HELLO TO HER.
WE SAW A NBER OF THE OTHER
HARVARD CRATION MEMBERS-HERE
ARE THE BOARD OF OVERSEERS, YOU
SEE THEY'RE WEARING THEIR
ELEGANT HATS.
JUST AFTER THE BOARD OF
OVERSEE
FACULTY BECOMING TO COME IN.
>> JUSTIN, CONGRATULATIONS, YOU
NEED TO GET BACK TOOUR CLASS.
AND ENJOY THE CEREMONY.T DAY,
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS, JUIN.
I THINK W EVEN SOME SOME
MEMBERS OF THE CAMBRIDGE CITY
COUNCIL WHO ARE COMING THROUGH
THE PROCESSIOTHERE, AND WE
LL HAVE -- WE WILL HAVE THE
ENTIRE PRESIDENT'S PROCESSION
LED BY THE SHEFF OF MIDDLESEX
COUNTY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I SAW HIM EARLIER MILLING
AROUND.
HE'S ALL READY.
YOU SEE THERE THOSE ROBES, THEY
MAY LOOK PINK TO YOU, BUT IN
FACT WE CALL THE CRIMSON.
TH LOOK A LITTLE PINK, BUT
THEY'RE THE STUDENTS WHO GOT THE
PhD, THE HIGHEST DEGREE THAT
HARVARD OFFERS.
>> WHAT YOU WILL SEE AS WE BEGIN
OFFERING THE DEGREES IS THAT THE
PhDS ARE AWARDED FIRST BY THE
DEAN OF THE FACULTY OF ARTS AND
SCIENCES AND THE DEAN OF THE
AND THEN AT THE VERY END OF THE
THE AWARDIN OF THE DEGREES WILL
BE, IN A SENSE, THE PRIDE IN
PLACE, THE UNDERGRADUATES WILL
BE GIVEN THEIR DEEES.
>> WE HAVE SOME SPECIAL
UNRADUATES THIS YEAR.
OBVIOUSLY AMIDSTHIS HUGE
NUMBER OF SDENTS EVERY ONE OF
THEM HAS A STORY T TELL.
BUT THERE ARE SOME SPECIAL RTS,
STUDENTS WHO A ACTUALLY
CHILDREN OF SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES THIS YEAR.
OUR PROVOST, ALAN GARBER, HIS
SON BEN GARBER IS GRADUATING
TODAY.
>> HE'S IN DUNSTER HOUSE.
>> NORS
SCHOOL, HIS DAUGHTER IS
GRADUATING TODAY.
>> I KNOW HER, SHE WAS A
RESEARCHER BEFORE SHE STARTED
SCHOOL HERENE SUMMER
WONDERFUL STUDENT.
>> JEREMY BLOXMAN, NOW THE DEAN
OF SCIENCE, HIS SON WILLIAM IS
GRADUATING FROM PFORZHEIMER
HOUSE, AND HE IS IN AN
UNDERGRADUATE CLAS
AND NICK KASHIN IS GDUATING AS
WELL.
WAS A SOCIOLOGY CONCENTRATOR,
THE SON OF BOB KASHIAN, A
WONDERFUL MAN.
HER DAUGHTER HANNAHS
GRADUATING FROM THE LAW SCHOOL
TODAY WITH A JD TODAY.
AND DAVID BLOOM, OUR COLLEAGUE
THE SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH,
A DISTINGUISHED ECONOMIST WHO
WORKS ON REALLY A GLOBAL
DEVELOPMENT, INTERNATIONAL
DEVE
GRADUATING FROM THE BUSINESS
SCHOOL WITH AN MBA.
THOSE ARE JUST SOME SMALL NUMBER
OF THE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
GETTING DEGREES TODAY.
>> AND FROM LOWELL HOUSE WE HAVE
A HUNDR AND SOME RHODES
SCHOLARS, STUDENTS WHO ARE GOING
ON FULBRIGHTS TO EVERY PART OF
THE WORLD.
THIS IS REALLY A TRANSITION FROM
THE LIFE TT THEY'VE KNOWN HERE
FOR THE LAST FR YEARS TO ALL
THE NEW THINGS THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO UNDERTAKE.
>> TS REALLY IS A
COMMENCEMENT.
THEY CALL IT A COMMENCEMENT, AND
AT'S A GREAT TERM FOR IT,
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, A HARVARD
DEGRS CERTAINLY NOTTHEN, IT
MAY BE THE END O THEIR TIME AT
HARVUT IT'S A BEGINNING.
IT REALLY A LAUNCHING OUT ON
THEIR CAREER.
AND THAT'S WHAT MAKES THIS
PROCESS SO EXCITING.
YOU SEEHESE STUDENTS AND YOU
SEE ARE ABOUT THE IMPACT OF ALL
OF THESE GREAT MINDS ARE GOING
TO HAVE.
ALL THEARD WORK THAT THEY PUT
INTO TO GET TO TS POINT, AND
THEN JUST IMAGINE THE THING
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO OVER
THE NEXT MANY DECADES.
IT'S RY TRAORDINARY.
THESE STUDENTS WILL TRULY CHANGE
THE WORLD AROUND US.
>> THIS IS CALLED AN ACADEMIC
FESTIVAL, AND INDEED IT IS A
GREAT ACADEMIC FESTIVAL, EVEN ON
A RAINY DAY LIKE THIS, A SENSE
OF ALL OF E SORT OF POMP AND
CIRCUMSTANCE, BUT ALSO THE FESS
VI
FESSTIVITIES OF THE LUNCHEONS.
>> THERE'S THE SHERIFF OF
MIDDLESEX COUNTY, THERE'S
PRESIDENT FAUST, DREW FAUST O
PRESIDENT, SHE IS PROCESSING IN
WITH THE ERIFF.
>> AND WITH JACQUELINE O'NEILL,
WHO'S BACK IS TOWARD US NOW, THE
UNIVERSITY MARSHAL.
>> A FEW PEOPLE BACK YOU CAN SEE
ALAN GARBER.
AS I SAID, HIS SON BEN GARBER IS
GRADUATING TODAY.
YOU SEE THE MEMBERS OF THE
CORPORATION JUST BEHIND LARRY,
THE FORMEY PRESIDENT OF THE
TUFTS UNIVERSITY, FORMER PRO
VEST AT M.I.T., HE'S COMING IN
AS WELL.
>> PRESIDENT A FELLOWS
DIVISION.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
RITUALS LIKE THIS DO IS TO ACT
OUT THE NATURE OF OUR COMMUNITY,
AND ACTUALLY IN PROCESSIONS, YOU
SEE A LITTLE BIT OF THE
HIERARCHY OF THE COMMUNITY.
THE PRESIDENT'SROCESSION
FOLLOWED BY THE PROFESSORS, AND
THEN EVENTUALLY THE
UNDERGRADUATES AND STUDENTS.
>> ALL OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE
CONTRIBUTED SO MUCH TO THIS
INSTITUTION,ELPING SHAPE IT
AN GUIDE IT.
THE CPORATION IN PARTICULAR,
VE.
THERE'S DREW APPLAUDING T
STUDENTS AS SHE WALKS THROUGH
INTO THE TERCENTENARY THEATER.
>> THIS IS HER0th YEAR AS
PRESI
CUSTOMARY, DELIVERS
BACCALAUREATE ADDRESSN THE DAY
BEFORE COMMENCEMENT.
YESTERDAY HER BACCALAUREATE WAS
EMELY INTERESTING.
>> THERE YOU SEE MEMBERS OF THE
FACULTY WALKING IN, PROFESSOR
FRANKLIN HUGGING ONE OF OUR
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS.
IT'S A TRADITION TO HAVE THE
FACULTY WALK THROUGH THE
STUDENTS.
IT'S A GREAT TRADITION.
>> ONE OF TH THINGS THAT DREW
FAUST SAID YESTERDAY SHE WANTED
NOTICING, NOT JUST BEING
NOTICED, SEEING RATHER THAN
FOCUSING ON BEING SEEN, AND
CONNECTING, AS SHE SAID,
CONNECTING YOUR MIND AND
AWARENESSO SOMETHING BEYOND
YOURSELF.
THAT'S AN EXTORDINARY MESSAGE,
AND IT ALSO WENT TOGETHER WITH
THE PHI BETA KAPPA ORTATION OF
SHERRY TURKLE YESTERDAY.
>> THEREOU SEE ROBERT KELSEY,
THE NEW AN.
>> HE'S AN ART HISTORIAN.
>> AND IF YOU CAN ROGNIZE
THEM, YOU SEE THE HONOR BANDS
ANDIR ESCORTS.
WE PROBABLY SHOULDN'T TELL YOU
WHO THEY ARE, BUT YOU WILL
RECOGNIZE SOME OF THEM TO BE
SURE.
>> IN MINUTE YOU'LL SEAL SEE
THE DEANS COMING IN.
THERE IS ANN CULHANE IN THE
BLACK HAT, FMER PRESIDENT OF
WELLESLEY AND PRESIDENT OF DUKE.
PEOPLE ARE FILING IN.
NOW YOU SEE THE DEANS.
THE'S PETER BOWL, WHO'S AN
ASSOCIATE PROVOST A HISTORIAN
O.
THERE YOU SEE FRANK DOYLE IN THE
PRCETON ROBE, BLUE WITH ORANGE
TRIM.
FRANK IS THE DEAN OF THE SCHOOL
OF ENGINEERING AND APPLIED
SCIENCES.
NEXT TO HIM MIKE SMH, WHOS
THE DEAN OF ARTS AND SCIENCES IN
THE HARVARD RE WITH THE BLACK
HAT.
KE, A COMPUTER SCIENTI IS
NOW THE DEAN --
>> AND JONATN WALPIN WHO IS
GREETING PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE AS HE COMES DOWN.
HE IS THE PUSSEY MINISTER.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU CAN SEE HUNT, HE'S THE DEAN
OF OUR -- DEAN OF CONTINUING
EDUCATION AT UNIVERSITY
EXTENSION.
EXTENSION SCHOOL A VERY
IMPORTANT OF THE UNIVERSITY.
HUNT HAS REALLY DONE
EXTRAORDINARY THINGS WITH THAT
.
AND YOU SEE THE FACULTY
FOLLOWING UP SOON BEHIND.
IT'S A WONDERFUL PROCESSION.
>> THERE'S MICHELE WILLIAMS.
>>ICHELE I THE NEW DEAN OF
THE SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND MICHELE IS A DISTINGUISHED
SCHOLAR IN PUBLIC HEALTH.
REALLY A WONDERFUL ADDITION TO
OUR ADMINISTRATION.
>> AND THERE ARE NEW NAMES.
>> DEAN OF THE BUSINESS SCHOOL
>> FOLLOWED BY THE DEAN OF THE
SCHOOL OF DIVINITY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
HART LAMBERT PASSING, OTHERS
SL.
I THINK THERE IS SOME PARENTS
MIXED IN WITH THEPROCESSION.
>> I THINK WE AO MIGHT
MENTION, CERTAINLY FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF THE COLLEGE, OUR
NEW DEANF STUDENTS THIS YEAR,
TIE O'DARE, WHO HAS DIDN'T
INTO THE DEAN OF STUDENTS, ONE G
OF THE MOST CHALLENGING YEARS
R HARVARD COLLEGE.
NOW YOU BEGIN TOEE THE
PROCESSION,HE ONES WHO WILL
TAKE THEIR PLACES IN THE
TERCENTENARY THEATER.
PEOPLE ASK WHO'S SPEAKING AT
HARVARD COMMENCEMENT, AND THERE
HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF WONDERFUL
EAKERS.
I MENTIONED SHERRY TURKLE WHO
WAS THE PHI BETA KAPPA ORATOR
YESTERDAY, AND TALKED ABOUT HOW
TECHNOLOGY MAKES US FORGET WHAT
WE KNOW ABOUT LIFE, AND
YOUR PHONE AND HAVE A REAL AY
CONVERSATION, A MESSAGE THAT IS
SOMEHOW ECHOED BY DREW FAUSTs
MESSAGE ON NOTICING.
>> SHIRLEY IS ALSO O THE
CORPORATIOAND A FORMER
PRESIDENT OF PRINCETON
UNIVERSITY
>> IF WE WERE TO GO ON WITH THE
PEOPLE W ARE SPEAKING AND WHO
HAVE SPOKEN, THE CLASS DAY
SPEAKER OF COURSE YESTERDAY FOR
OUR UNDERGRADUATES WAS JOE
BIDEN.
IT WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY SPEECH.
>> REALLY A CALL TO ACTION
JOE BIDEN'SEEN A SENATOR FOR
36 YEARS A THEN VICE PRESIDENT
FOR EIGHT YEAR A MAN, HE JOKED
AT T BEGIN OF HIS SPEECH, THAT
HE WAS THE VICE PRESIDENT THAT
HAD THE FEWEST ASSETS OF ANY IN
HISTORY, IN SUCH A LONG
DISTINGUISHED CAREER OF SERVICE
WHERE HIS REWARDS ARE NOT
FINANCIAL BUT REALLY IN SO MANY
YS HE HAS HELPED THE LIVES OF
SO MANY AMERICANS.
>> WELL, HE WAS REALLY A
CHALLENGE TOUR STUDENTS TO SAY
SOMEHOW 9% OF YOU WERE
CONSIDERING A JOB IN PUBLIC
SERVICE AND TH HAS TO CHANGE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> HE SPOKE OF HIS OWN
GENERATION AND THE CHALLENGES
THAT WERE FACEDY THE SA SAY
NATI OF MARTIN LUTHER KINGND
ROBERT KENNEDY AND REBUILDING
AMERICA IN THE WAKE OF THE
VIETNAM WAR.
HE SAID THIS IS THE MAGNITUDE OF
E
TO
I MIGHTLSO MENTION THAT FORMER
ASSISTANT ATTOEY GENERAL SALLY
YATES SPOKE ATARVARD LAW
SCHOOL YESTERDAY, AND AT THE
KENNEDY SCHOOL'S CLASS DAY WAS
JOHN KERRY.
TODAY WE ALSO WILL HAVE A
SPEECH, THE ONE MAJOR SPEECH
THIS AFTERNOON, ASIDE FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S REMARKS, WHICH ARE
IMPORTANT, WE'LL HAVE A SPEECH
BY MARK ZUCKERBERG, WHO IS THE
ONE HONORARY DEGREE CANDIDATE
THAT EVERYONE KNOWS ABOUT.
I MIGHTENTION THAT MARK LT
HARVARD, A EVERYONE KNOWS,
AFTER HIS SOPHOMORE YEAR.
HIS GIRLFRIEND, THEN GIRLFRIEND,
PRISCILLA CHEN WAS A STUDENT IN
LOWELL HOUSE, AND WENT ON
BECOME A PEDIATRICIAN IN THEAY
A
WITH MARK IS THE FOUNDER OF THE
CHAN-ZKERBERG ITIATIVES THAT
REALLY ARE AED AT MAKING A
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES OF THE
NEXT GENERATION IN ECATION AND
IN HEALTH.
AND PRISCIL WAS A LOWELL HOUSE
STUDENT AND WAS KIND ENOUGH TO
COME BACK AND TALK WITH SOME OF
>> HIGH HIVE TO RAKESH KHURANA.
>> SO PRISCILLA CAME TO A COFFEE
WITH SOME OF OUR LOWELL HOUSE
SENIORS WHO ARE GOING IO
MEDICI.
AND THAT WAS JUST A WONDERFUL
>> YOU PICTURE THERE ON
THE LEFT, DIANE PAULIS,HE
ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF THE
CAMBRIDGE. THEATER HERE IN
SHE'S UP THERE ON THE STAGE.
>> I MIGHT MENTION THE BACCALAU
YESTERDAY, NOW WE BEGIN TO SEE
SOME OF THE HONANDS APPEARING.
AMONG THEM -- WELL, WE CAN'T
REALLY MENTION, WE CAN TALK
ABOUT THEIR ESCORTSN ANY CASE.
INTERESTING, IT INCLUNG  VERY
READINGS AND PRAYERS FROMHE
SCRIPTURES OF BUDDHISTS, OF
COUR FROM THE KORAN, FROM THE
BIBLE, FROM THE HEBREW BIBLE,
AND THE PRAYER IN THE NAVAJO
LANGUAGE.
SOMETHING THAT REALLY REPRESENTS
THE BREADTH OF THE CULTURAL AND
RELIOUS TRADITIONS OF HARVARD
COLLEGE IN THIS DAY INAGE.
A REAL RICHNESS OF DIVERSITY.
>> THERE ARE SOME OF THE
UNDERGRADUATES OF QUINCY HOUSE,
THE FACULTY ARE CONTINUING TO
PROCESS IN.
>> THE
>> THE MAJOR REUNIONS, THE 25th
AND THE 50th MARCHFTER THE
FACULTY, AND --
>> THE CHIEF MARSHALF THE
ALUMNIS THIS YEAR OF THE 25th IS
R OWN ATTORNEY GENERAL,AURA
HEALY FROM MASSACHUSETTS, WHO IS
IN THE 25th REUNION CLASS.
>> MY BROTHER, JONATHAN SCHRAG
IS ACTUALLY ITHE 25th REUNION
CLASS AS WELL.
MY MOTHER, IT'S HER 55th
REUNION.
IT'S NICE TO CELEBRATE WITH
THEM.
>> IN THE 50th REUNION CLASS IS
WHAT THEY SOMETIMES CALL THE
EVERGREEN DEAN, THOMAS DINGMAN,
WHO IS THE DN OF FRESHMEN NOW.
AND ALSO JOHN LITHW, WHO
RECEIVED THE ARTS MEDICAL
>> JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO.
>
LAUNCHED OUR FIRST CEREMONIES.
SO JOHN IS AO IN THE 50th
REUNION CLASS.
AND  THINK I SAW HIM.
HE MAY WELL BE AN ESCORT, BUT IN
ANY CASE, HE IS HERE AT THE
CEREMONIES TODAY.
THE HONORARY DEGREE CANDIDAS
ARE WELCOMED AT THE NIGHT BEFE
COMMCEMENT AT A GALA BEGINNER
THERE ARE PEOPLE FROM ACROSS THE
UNIVERSI, AND IN WHICH THE
HONORARY DEGREE CANDIDATES ARE
RECOGNIZED INDIVIDUALL BY THE
PRESIDENT N BY THE
ASSE
ASSEMBLED PEOPLE FROM
EVERYWHERE.
WE HAVE ABOUT 10 PhDS THI YE.
>> REALLY.
THAT'S A BIG NUMBER THIS YEAR.
>> ITS A BIG NUMBER, DOING
EVERYTHING FROM WORKI ON
ISSUES OF MUSLIM RELATIONS IN
FRCE TO BIBLICAL STUDIES.
>> YOU SEE THERE UNIVERSITY OF
CAFORNIA WROTE PROFESSOR
JO A PROFESSOR IN EOB, HE
IS IN THE 65th REUNION ASS.TUDI
>> IT'S AMAZING.
WHAT OF THE THINGS PEOPLE SAY IS
YOU SEE THE WHOLE LIFE CYCLE
PASS BEFORE YOU HERE.
SO IT IS I THAT SENSE AN EVENT
OF THE LIFE CYCLE.
IN THE WHITE HOOD THERE SO TOM
KELLY, OUR PROFESSOR OF MUSIC.
>> HERE'S ALAN GARBER, PROVOST
THE STAGE.
>> THE FACULTY WILL STAY DRY
TODAY.
THERE IS NO RAIN PLAN REALLY IF
IT STARTS TO RAIN HEAVILY FOR
THE UNDERGRAATES.
AND I MIGHT RECALL THAT IS
WHOLE SPACE IS CALLED THE
TERCENTENARY THEATER BECAUSE IT
WAS CONSTRUCTED AS SUCH REALLY
FOR THEARVARD 300th
ANNIVERSARY IN 36.
ANDT THAT EVENT THERE WE
PEOPLE LITERALLY FROM ALL THE
GREAT UNIVEITIES OF THE WORLD,
D ITAINED LIKE MAD.
AND THINK SOMEONE, PERHAPS
SAY THIS IS HOW HARVARD SOAKS TO
THE RICH.
AND IT WAS JUST A DOWNPOUR.
>> IT'S REALLY NOT SO BAD TODAY.
>> IT'S NOT SO BAD TODAY.
AND THERE ISO OPTION REALLY.
IF YOU CAN IMAGINE THE 10,000
PEOPLE WHO ARE ASSEMBLED IN THE
TERCENTENARY THEATER AND AROUND
.
THERE'S  INDR SPACE.
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE THE PUBLIC
HAULS IN THE SCIENCE CENTER AND
IN ALL OF THE HOUSES AND IN
SANDERS THEATER WHERE PEOPLE CAN
WATCH THESE PROCEEDINGS AND
LISTEN TO US AND HAVE A PRETTY
GOOD VIEW OF WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> WELL, NOBODY IS GOING TO GET
SUNBURNED DAY.
>> WE HAVE THE BEST SEATS IN THE
HOUSE, DAN.
WE'RE DRY, WE CAN SEE EVERYTHING
ONHE MONITOR AND WE CAN SEET
ALL LIVE, TOO.
IT'S NDERFUL.
THERE YOU SEE SIB FERBA, ONE OF
THE GREAT PROFESSORS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF ECONOMICS.
AND SOME OF MY DIVINITY SCHOOL
COLLEAGUES IN FRONT.
HEY, CHRIS.
GETTING ALL THE FACULTY ON THE
STAGE IS A BIT OF A CHALLENGE.
YOU CAN SEE EVERY ONCE IN A
WHILE OUR UNIVERSITY MAHAL,
JACQUELINE'NEILL IS SORTF
BEACONING PEOPLE TO MOVE FASTER.
BUT THERE REALLY IS NO HURRY ON
A DAY LIKE TODAY.
IT IS A DAY ONCE IN A LIFETIME,
AND FOR FACTY AND STUDENTS
ALIKE, THIS IS A MAGICAL
SPIRITUAL.
THERE'S MARK WOLF, FAMOUS
SCHOLAR OF BACH, MEMBER OF THE
MUSIC DEPARTME.
>> THE DEAN OF THE LAW SCHOOL,
DEAN OF THE BUSINESS SCHOOL.
OF COURSE THIS IS MARTHA'S LAST
YEAR AT THE LAW SCHOOL.
A FFICULT TIME THROUGH THE
TIME OFPHEAVAL DISCUSSION
ABOUT RACE AND ABOUT POLITICS, I
THINK SHE STEERED US THROUGH
THAT TIME VERY, VERY ABLY.
>> AND THAT DISCUSSION, OF
COURSE, IS TAKING PLACE ACROSS
THE COLLEGE THIS YEAR AS WELL.
A LOT OF ECONOMIC ISSUES AND
RACE AND CULTURAL ISSUES, THE
CLASS THAT IS GRADUATING TODAY
BEGAN THEIR SENIOR YEAR WITH THE
STRIKE OF THE DINING HALL
WORKERS.
AND ALL OF THEM HAD TO PULL
TOGETHER IN NEW WAYS TO BEGIN TO
TAKE UP SOME OF THE
REONSIBILITY OF CREATING
COMMUNITY WITH THE DINING HALL
STRI
OF COURSE, THE DINING HALLS ARE
PART OF OUR FAMILY, REALLY, AT
HARVARD HOUSING.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HERE THE FACULTY CONTINUE TO
WALK IN.
>> THERE'S WARN GOLDFARB, THE
PROFESSOR OF PHILOSOPHY.
>> I SEE RICHARD LAZARUSHERE
IN THE MIDDLE, RICHARD IS A
DISTINGUISHED ENVIRONMENTAL LAW
PROFESSOR ANDLSO AN EXPERT ON
THE SUPME COURT AT TH LAW
SCHOOL.
STDING THERE WALKI WITH MARK
RUE, ANOTHER FACT ALL MEMBERN
E LAW SCHOOL.
THEY'RE CONGRATULATE THE LAW
SCHOOL GRADUATES DAY.
>> A FESTIVAL OF UMBRELLAS,
ALLY.
IT'S A GOOD THI TT DANND I
ARE TOGETHER.
I OW SOME OF THE PEOPLE ON THE
FACULTY, AND HE KNOWS A LOT OF
THE PEOPLE I DON'T KNOW.
>> WE COMPLIMENT EACH OTHER
WELL, DIANA.
>> WE DO.
ONE OF THE THINGS TO REMEMBER IS
THERE IS LOT OF TRADITION ONCE
THERE ARE TWO PIECES OF MUSIC
T
INCLUDES DINE SALVAM FACIGHT
AT THEEGINNING, AND PSALM79,
GIVE EARY CHILDREN TO MY LAW,
AND THAT ALSO IS SUNG IN ST.
MARTIN'S TUNE AT EVERY
COMMENCEMENT.
BUT THIS COMMENCEMENT THERE'S
ALSO A PREMIERE, A WORLD
PREMRE OF A PIECE CALLED "TO
THE RIVER CHARLES."
AND THAT WILL BE THEIRST TIME
THIS PIECE BY MICHAEL SCHACHTER
PERFORMED.
THERE'S A COMMENCEMENT CHOIR
THAT COULDN'T VISES OF STUDENTS
WHO ARE CHOIRIALL MIND, NOT
USUALL THEENIOR CLASS,
USUALLY FRESHMEN, SOPHOMORES AND
JUNIORS WHO STAY.
AND OF COURSE A COMMENCEMENT
BAND.
>> AND WE'LL HAVE THE LIT
INADDRESS, AND THE ENGLISH
ADDRESS BOTH BY MBERS OF THE
COLLEGE AND ONE OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE GRADUATED SCHOOL, AND
THIS YEAT WILL BE SOMEBODY
FROM THE DIVINITY SCHOOL.
>> YES, I'M QUITE EXCED TO
HEAR THAT.
THE MEMBERS OF THE GRADUATED
SCHOOL AS WELL AS THE
UNDERGRADUATES COMPETE VERY
FIERCELY FOR THESE ROLES IN
SPEAKING AT COMMENCEMENT.
>> THE STUDENTS FOR THE LATIN
HAVE A TRANSLATION.
UNFORTUNATELY, MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE AREN'T QUITE SO LUCKY,
SO THEY MAY NOT UNDERSTAND
WHAT GOING ON.
>> THERE ARE TIME LINES THIS
ARF
THE DAY, BUT AS I THINK ABOUT
OUR OWN PSONAL TIME LINE VERY
EARLY IN THE FALL WE WERE LUCKY
TO HAVE AN ADDRESS BY SUCHI FROM
MYANMAR, AND THAT WAS VERY
WIDELY ATTENDED, AND SHE WAS
THEN HOSTED FOR A DINNER AT
LOWELL HOUSE.
>>O LOWELL HOUSE IN YOUR ROLE
AS FACULTY DEAN, LOWELL HOUSE IS
ABOUT TO GO THROUGH A TIME OF
UPHEAVAL.
THERE'S A HOUSE RENEWAL, WHICH
IS A WONDERFUL THING, RENEWAL IS
A GOOD THING, AND HARVARD IS
SPENDING A LOT OF MONEY TO
UPGRADE AND RENEW THE HOUSES,
COMPLETELY RENOVATE THEM, B OF
COURSE IT ANS YOU ARE GOING TO
BE DISPLACED FOR THE NEXT YEAR
AND A HALF OR SO.
>> WE INVITED ALL OF OUR SENIORS
D THEIR PARTS FOR THE USUAL
RECEPTION IN THE FACULTY DEAN'S
RESIDENCE LAST EVENING.
WE'LL HAV OUR SENIOR COMMON
ROOM FOR LUNCH AND A POACHED
SALMON IN OUR RESIDENCE THIS
NOON, AND THEN AFTER THE
AWARDING OF THE DEGREES, THE
DIPLOMAS, BUTOMORROW WE WILL
T.
BACALLY THEING V WILL
COME UP AND DISPLACE THE FIRST
FLOOR OF THE FACULTY DEAN'S
RESIDENCE AND B THE PROCESS
OF TAKING APART IT --
>> JERRY BLOCKS MAN DEAN O
SCIENCE, JEAN SHAW, CHAIR OF
PLANETARY EARTH AND SCIENCES.
>> SO IT'S A VERY BITTERSWEET
TIME AT LOWELL HOUSE.
THE CRT YARDS, THE PUBLIC
ROOMS, THE STUDENT ROOMS ALL
UNDERGOING A CONSIDERABLE
RENOVATION, AND AND THEN WE'LL
BE AWAY FOR TWO YEARS.
>> SO TWO YEARS IS QUITE A LONG
TIME.
>> HOW DO YOU THINK ABOUT
HOLDING YOUR COMMUNITY TOGETHER,
OF THE SPECIAL THINGS AT HARVARD
ISHE HOUSE SYSTEM WHERE IT
TAKES THIS HUGE COMMUNITY AND
COMMUNITIESITHIN IT.ANAGEABLE
HOW DO YOU MAINTAIN THAT KIND OF
SENSE MUCH FAMILY DURING A TIM
WHEN YOUE NO LONGER THINKING
TOGETHER.
>> WE'RE GOING TO THINK BEEN
THINNG ABOUT THIS FOR A COUPLE
OF YEARS IN ANTICIPATION OF
THIS.
WE DO HAVE A LOT O PEOPLE
COMMITTED TO THIS, TUTORS AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENIOR COMMON
ROOM AND OF COURSE WE ARE
OURSELVES.
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
DOROTHY AND I ARE STAYING ON AS
FACULTYEANS BECAUSE WE HAVE
BEEN PRETTY EFFECTIVE OF
CREATING A SENSE OF COMMUNITY
THERE, AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE ON BOARD TO DO IT.
>> YOU JUST SAW THE VERY END OF
THE PRESSION.
HERE'S JOHN SHAW WALKING TO HIS
PLACE.
>> AND THE MARSHALS WILL COME
AND TELL THE CHIEF MARSHAL THAT
THE PEOPLE HAVE -- THAT EVERYONE
HAS BEEN SEATED.
AND WE HAVE JOHN LEVY FROM
LOWELL HOUSE, WHO IS ONE OF THE
MARSHALS WHO IS CHARGED WH
SEATING THE UNDERGRADUATES
THIS IS A CONSIDERABLE TASK, AS
YOU MIGHT IMAGINE.
>> THE UNDERGRADUATES ARE STILL
FILING IN, IN ANOTHER FEW
MINUTES EVERYBODY WILL BE IN
THEIR PLACES AND READY TO GO.
LOOK AT THE FACES OF ONE OF THE
UNDERGRADUATES.
>> FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO REMEMBER
CARIDGE OR KNOW CAMBRIDGE FROM
A FEW YEARS AGO, THE HEART OF
THE COMMUNITY IN THE COURSE OF
HOUSE RAL WILL BE WHAT WAS
FORMERLY THE INN AT HARVARD A
THE CORNERF HARVARD AND THE -
>> SO MOST OF THOSE STUDENTS
WILL LIVE THERE.
>> NOT MOST, THE SOPHOMORES WILL
LIVE THER WE'LL HAVE OUR HOUSE
OFFIS THERE, OUR COMMON ROOM,
OUR WEEKLY TEAS THERE, HIGH
TABLE, WEEKLY DINNERS, ET
CETERA.
THE STUDENTS WHO ARE JUNIORS AND
SENIORS HAVE APARTMENTS UP AND
DOWN PRESCOTT STREET AND ABOVE
JP LICKS ON MASS. AVE. AND ABOVE
THE BOOKSTORE.
THAT'S JACKIE O'NEILL, THE
UNIVERSITY MARSHAL.
>> JACKIE O'NEILL'S TALKING TO
PEOPLE ON THE STAGE, GETTING
READY TO START THE CEREMONY
WHERE SHE WILL INTRODUCE THE
SHERIFF OF MIDDLESEX COUNTY WHO
WILL CALL THE MEETING TO ORDER.
>> TALKING TO THE GENERAL
COUNSEL OF THE UNIVERSITY.
THE HATS, WOW.
IN PCE OF TOP HATS WHERE WOMEN
OF THE CORPORATION AND OF THE
OVERSEERS HAVE QUITE A LOT OF
LATITUDE.
>> THEY GET TO WEAR A LOT OF
INTERESTING STYLE.
THE QUEEN OF ENGLAND WOULD BE
JEALOUS.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT AS THE CONFERRING OF
CONFERRED BY WHAT IS CALLED THE
SPEECH BACK OF THE PRESIDENT.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE WHOLE GROUP
STANDS TOGETHER, AND THE
PRESIDENT, HAVING BEEN
INTRODUCED TO THIS GROUP BY THE
RESPECTIVE DEAN OF THE SCHOOL,
CONFERS UPON THEM THE DEGREE FOR
WHICH THEY ARE QUALIFIED.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND THEN EH UNDERGRADUATE
HOUSE HAS THEIR OWN CEREMONY
WHERE INDIVIDUALLY THEIR NAMES
GET CALLED OUT, AND THE SAME
WITH EACHF THE SCHOOLS.
>> S.
>> S LATER THISFTERNOON I
WILL BE PUTTING THE TWO PhDS IN
THE SCHOOL OF ENGINEERING IN
APPLIED SCIENCES, ANDHAT GETS
DONE INDIVIDUALLY AFTER THE
GREES ARE CONFERRED BY THE
PRESIDENT EN MASSE.
>> AND IT WAS THE CASE FOR MANY
DIPLOMA IF YOU WANTED A DIPLOM
THE DIPLOMA WAS EXTRA.
>> WELL, YOU STILL HAVE TO PAY
FOR IT, BUT IN A MUC LONR
WAY.
SO, YES, THE RITL CONFERRING
OF THE DEGREES AND THAT WILL S
THIS CONFERRING OF DEGREES I
ONE OF THE OLDEST IN THE UNITED
STATES, GOING ON NOW FOR SOME
300-PLUS YEARS.
WARD THE END OF THE WHOLE
REMONY WHEN THE MEETING IS
JOURNALED BY THE SHERIFF, THERE
WILL ALSO BE THIS CEREMONIAL
RINGING OF BELLS ALL AROUND
CAMBRIDGE, INCLUDING THE BELL OF
THE FIRST PARISH ACROSS MASS.
AVENUE, THE FIRST UNITARRIAN
PARISH, W RANGE DURING THE
VERY EARLY HARVARD COMMENCEMENT
AS WELL.
>> I THINK WE'RE ALMOST READY TO
START.
THERE YOU SEE JONATHAN,UR
COLLEAGUE FROM THE LAW SCHOOL,
TALKING TO MARK ZUCKERBERG, WHO
WILL BE OUR COMMENCEMEN SPEAKER
LATER IN THE DAY.
>> EVERYONE ON THE PLATFORM IS
Y, AND UNDER THIS CANOPY OF
TREES THERE DOES -- WILL PROVIDE
A BITF PROTECTION.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE LEARN
COMMENCEMENTHAT SECRETARY OF T
STATE GEORGE MARSHAL SPOKE AND
DESCRIBED WHAT BECAME THE
MARSHALL PLAN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THERE YOU SEE SOME OF THE
HONORARY DEGREES UPTHERE.
YOU CAN SEE THE MAN SITNG DOW
THERE,E MAY BE RECOGNIZED BY
EVERYBODY, JAMES EAR JONES, THE
GREAT ACTOR.
HE RECENTLY APPEARE AT THE
A.R.T., THE A BEAUTIFUL
PRESENTATION AT THE "NIGHT OF
THE IGUANA" TENNESSEE WILLIAMS
PLAY.
PELE HAVE THEIR RAIN PONCHOS
ON, THERE READY TO GO.
>> AT 9:45, YOU SHOULD HAVE THE
CEREMONY BEGINNING WITH RNG
OF THE BELL, AND BY 11:30, IT
SHOULD BE ENDED.
WE'RE ON AIR PRETTY MUCH
PROCEEDS, BECAUSE IT HAS ITS OL
SORT OF RITUAL DIMENSIONS THAT
ARE CAREFULLY SCRIPTED BY THE
MARSHAL OF THE UNIVERSITY.
AMAZING TO SEE THAT AISLE
CLEARED NOW, AND THERE'S RAKESH
KHU
KHURANA.
>> JACKIE O'NEILL WILL BEGIN THE
DAY.
PEOPLE ARE ALMOST THERE.
>> PRESUMABLYRADUATES OF THE
MEDICAL SCHOOL.
>> YES, WEARING THEIR
STETHOSCOPES.
EVERY SCHOOL LIKES
SOMETHING SPECIAL TO THEIR
SCHOOL.
>> SO THE MEETING, AND IT'S
DESCRIBED AS A MEETING, WILL BE
KOUTOUJIAN, THE SHERIFF OF
MIDDLESEX UNTY.
>> HE HAS QUITE A FLARE FOR
CALLING THE MEETING TO ORDER.
>> I THINK HIS GOLD-TIPPED BATON
MUST BELONG TO THE UNIVERSITY.
I DON'T THINIT IS USUALLY
WITHIN HIS --
>> BUTE SEEMS TO KNOW HOW TO
USE IT.
>> HE KNOWS HOWO USE IT, YE
THEN THERE WILL BE A CHAPLAIN OF
THE DAY TO INTRODUCE THE
PROCEEDINGS WITH A BRIEF PRAYER.
ALANNAOPENHAVER SULLIVAN
AND THA HAS BECOME RATHER A
ROLE THAT ROTATES.
WE HAVE HAD A MUSLIM CHAPLAIN
INTRODUCE THE CEREMIES AS
WELL.
>> THE RAIN IS COMING DOWN
LITTLE BIT HARDER RIGHT NOW.
>> IT IS.
>> IT MAY LIGHTEN UP IN A LITTLE
BIT.
>> UNDERGRADUATES WERE TOLD THEY
CANNOT BRING UMBRELLAS, SO THERE
THEY ARE.
>> THEY'RE HEARTY.
>> THEY ARE.
AND IT'S A GREAT DAY FOR THEM,
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> VERY SOON THE PEOPLE ON
STAGE, THE CORPORATION MEMBERS,
THEOARD OF OVERSES, THE
S, THE FACULTY WHO ARE
ACCOMPANYING THE HONORARY DEGREE
RECIP
RECIPIENTS, AND THE HONORARY
DEGREE RECIPIENTSHEMSELVES
WILL
JACQUELINE O'NEILL WILL STEP UP
AND THE CEREMONY WILL BEGIN.
>> T MAN IN BLUE IS RICHARD
TERENT, DIRECTOR OF CLASSICS,
AND HE IS THE ONE THAT RUNS T
COMPITION FOR THE ORATIONS.
YOU CAN IMAGINE IT IS NOT
EVERYONE WHO FEELS COMFOABLE
BEFORE SPEAKING BORE 10,000
PEOPLE WITHOUT NOS, BY THE
WA
THESE ARE MEMORIZED.
>> THERE IS.
YOU MAY RECOGNIZE STANDING RIGHT
SIDE HIM ISRY LEWIS GATES,
SKIPGATES.
>> THERE IS ONE OTHER VERY
RECOGNIZABLE HONORAND, BUT NOW I
AM NOT SEEING HER.
>> I DON'T SEE HER.
>> SHE IS AN ACTRESS.
>> SHE IS A WONDERF ACTRESS.
ICTUALLY WAS WITH HER WHEN S
REIVED AN HONORARY DEGREE
YEARS AGO FROM TRINITY COLLEGE.
>> WONDERFUL.
>> I IRELAND.
>> WHAT A SIGHT.
>> ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW, T LIGHT
IS QUITE AUTIFUL.
>>T IS BEAUFUL.
>> IT'S SOFT.
THE FINAL WAVE OF UNDERGRADUATES
AR COMIN INTO THE THEATER.
THEY ARE COMING IN TOAKE THEIR
SEATS, BUTE SEE THE VERY END
THERE.
I THINK THOSEAST HANDFUL OF
UNDERGRADUATES ARE NOW ABOUT TO
COME DOWN THE MIDDLE AISL AND
THEN WE'LL BE READY TO BEGIN.
ALAN GARBER IS STANDING THERE,
OUR PROVOST, TALKI TO
JACQUELINE O'NEILL.
>> IHINK WE SHOULD RECOGNIZE
THE FACT THAT THIS YEAR WE HAVE
A NEW SORT OF PERSON WHO RUNS
THE WHOLE OF THE COMMENCENT.
STEVEN MAGRO, AND HE HAS DONE A
WONDERFUL JOB.
THIS IS ASOU MIGHT IGINE AN
ENORMOUSLY COMPLEX STANG
EVENT.
THE PROFESSIONAL ORDER AND THE
LINES AND THE SCRIPT FOR WHAT
HAPPENS IS -- IT'S A VERY HARD
JOB.
>> RAN THIS FOR HOW MANY YEARS?
>> SO FOR STEPHEN TO COME IN AND
TAKE THIS OVER AND LEARN ALL OF
THE TRADITIONS AND ALL OF THE
CUSTOMS, IT'S REALLYIL GREAT
CHALLENGE.
HE'S DONE A WONDERFUL JOB.
THERE YOU SEE MARK ZUCKERBERG
AND JAMES EARL JONE
>> AND THERE ARE OTHERS HERE
WHOM PEOPLE WILL RECOGNIZE
IMMEDIATELY FOR THE IMPACT OF
THEIR WORK AND FOR THE IMPACT OF
THEIR MUSIC
>> THE MARSHALS ARE WHAT WE
WOULD GENERALLY CALL THE USHERS
AT THIS EVENT.
>> PEOPLE ARE TAKING THEIR
SEATS.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE ARE ABOUT
READY TO BEGIN.
THERE IS --
>> WELL, ONE OF THE GREAT
SURPRISES.
EVERYONE WHO HAS THE PROGRAM
WILL NOTICE, BUT ITS JOHN
WILLIAMS, THE GREAT COMPOSURE.
>> I WONDER I WE'LL HEAR A
LITTLE STAR WARS FROM THEAND
TODAY.
ALTHOUGH HE'S CREATED SO MANY
ICONIC MUSICAL SCORES FOR GREAT
MOVIES.
>> AMONG THE BEL THAT WILL
TO AT THE END OF THE CEREMONY
IS THE 17 BELLS RG AT LOWELL
HOUSE, BLS THAT WERE NEWLY
CAST,
SHIPPED TO THE UNITED STATES,
D
REALLY HISTORIC LOWELL HOUSE
BES BACK TO THEIR HOME, THEIR
MONASTERY IN RUSSIA, AND THAT
YEAR OF THE BELL EXCHANGE WAS
ONE OF THE BEST AND MOST
INTERESTING YEARS IN OUR TIME AS
HOUSE DEANS.
>> THERE YOU SEE DREW FAUST IN
IT'S NOT THE MOST COMFORTABLE
CHAIR  THE WORLD, BUT SHE
DIDN'T HAVE TO SIT THERE T
LONG, JUST FOR A FEW HOURS
TODAY.
ANDHE WILL STAY SEATED
THROUGHOUT MT OF THE DAY.
THERE YOU S ALL O OUR
HONORARY DEGREE RECIPIENTS.THER
SPECTACULAR ACTRESS.
SITTING NEXT TO OUR
DISTINGUISHED PROFESSOR OF
COMPUTER SCIENCE EMERITUS NOW,
MICHAEL RABIN, WONDERFUL
COLLEAGUE INCHOOL OF
ENGINEERING AND ALIED
SCIENCES.
HE'S ALSO RECEIVING AN HONORARY
DEGREE.
HARVARD HAS THAT USUALLY, NOT
EVERY YEAR, BUT ALMOST EVERY
YEAR THERE IS ONE MEMBER OF THE
HARVARD FACULTY USUALLY ANY
EMERITAS THAT RECEIVE AN
HONORARY DEGREE.
WE'RE WAITING FOR THE VERY LAST
STUDENTS TO CE IN, BUT WE CAN
SEE THE VERY END OF IT.
>> WE'VE SAID THAT BEFORE.
>> I KNOW.
IT'S LITTLE SLOW THIS YEAR.
I WONDERHAT'S SLOWING IT DOWN.
BUT THE CEREMONY WILL BEGIN
SHORTLY.
WE'RE JUST ABOUT TO SEE BEN LEVY
COME DOWN THE AISLE AND TELL
JACKIE O'NEILL THAT EVERYONE IS
SEATED.
AND IF GETTING INTO THE
TERCENTENARY THEATER IS COMPLEX,
GETTING OUT IS ALSO COMPLEX.
AND THERE IS T PSIDENT'S
PROCESSION THAT WILLRETIRE,
WI LEAVE THE STAGE AND GO DOWN
THE PROCESSIONAL CENTER AISLE.
AFTER THAT, IT'S SHEER CHAOS.
THERE' THE BELL.
(BELLS RINGING)
>> AND NOW THE CEREMONY BEGINS.
>> MR. SHERIFF, PRAY, GIVE US
OR
ORDER.
>> AS THE HIGH SHERIFF OF
MIDDLESEX COUNTY, I DECLARE THAT
THE MEETING WILL BE IN ORDER!
[APPLAUSE]
>> PLEASE RISE FOR THE NATNAL
ANEM AND REMAIN STANDING FOR
THE CHAPLAIN OF THE DAY WHO WILL
OPEN THE EXERCISES WITH A
PRAYE.
OH, SAY CAN YOU SEE
BY THE DAWN'S EAY LIGHT
WHAT SO PROUDLY WE HAILED
AT THE TWILIGHT'S LALEAMING
WHOSE BROAD STRIPES AND BRIGHT
STARS
THRU THE PERILOUS FIGHT
O'ER THE RAMRTS WE WATCHED
WERE SO GALLANTLY STREAMING
AND THE ROCKET'S RED GLARE
THE BOMBS BURSTING IN AIR
GAVE PROOFHROUGH THE NIGHT
THAT OUR FLAG WAS STILL THERE
D
BANNER YET WAVE
O'ER THE LAND OF THEREE
AND THE HOME OF THE BRAVE
>> LET US PRAY.
HOLY GOD, KNOWN BY MANY NAMES,
WE GATHER TODAY BRIMMING WITH
JOY AND OVERFLOWING WITH
GRITUDE.
WEIVE THANKS FOR THESE
FRIEND, COMMUNITIES ANDAMILIES
EDUCATORS WHO HAVE GIVEN THEM
ROOTS TO GROUND THEM AND THE
SUPPORT TO REACH FOR THE SKY.
WE ASK YOUR BLESSING UPON THEM
AT THIS MOMENT, GNT THEM
IMAGINATIONS TO ENVISION NEW
WAYS OF HOW THE WORLD MIGHT BE.
GRANT THEM WISDOM FROM
ANCESTORS, KNOWN AND UNKNOWN.
GRANT THEM CEASELESS CURIOSITY
ABOUT CREATION AND HUMAN KIND.
GRANT THEM CONVICTION FOR
JUSTICE AND COMMITMENT TO
EQUITY.
GRANT THE ATTENTIVENESS TO THE
GIFTS AND NEEDS OF THOSE OUND,
WHETHER THEY BE LOVED ONES OR
STRANGERS.
MAY THEYUILD LIVES WHERE THEIR
DEEP GLADNESS MEETS THE WOR'S
DEEP NEED.
GOD, YOU HAVE CALLED US TO
VENTURES OF WHICH WEANNOT SEE
THE ENDING BY PATHS YET
UNTRODDEN.
GIVE US FAITH TO GO OUT WITH
GOOD COURAGE, NOT KNOWING WHERE
WE GO, BUT WITH THE CONFIDENCE
AND KNOWLEDGE OF WHERE WE HE
BEEN.
FILL US WITH PURPOSE AND JOY SO
THAT WE MIGHT GO OUT TO BETTER
SERVE THIS WORLD TO BE
HARBINGERS OF HOPE, SEEKERS OF
JUSTICE, CULTIVATORS OF
COMPASSION, ARCHITECTS OF
BEAUTY, GIVERS OF LIGHT, AND
BEARERS OF LOVE.
AMEN.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
>> LATIN SALUTATORY, CANDIDATE
FOR THE DEGREE OF BACHELOR OF
ARTS, JESSICA RACHAEL UECK.
[APPLAUSE]
SENIOR ENGLISH ADDRESS, WHEN WE
FALL IN ONE PIECE, CANDIDATE FOR
THE DEGREE OF BACHELOR OF ARTS,
AUGUSTE ROC.
[APPLAUSE]
>> WHEN I WAS SIX YEARS OLD, I
LEARNED SUDDENLYHAT THE WOR
IS A SCARY PLACE.
ON ABEAUFUL, CRISP BLUE SKY
MORNING ON MY FIRST DAY OF FIRST
GRADE, A CINEMATIC FIREBALL
ROA
NTER AND FIXED ME TO THE
LIVING ROOM WINDOW.
OUR APARTMENT BUILDING SHOOK
LIKE AN EARTHQUAKE, THENHE
LIGHTS WENT OUT.
THE POWER OUTAG ENDING SESAME
STREET EARLY A WITH NO
ELEVATOR, MY MOM AND DAD RAN
DOWN 22 FLIGHTS OF STAIRS TO MY
BUILDING'S LOBBY.
AS THE FIRST TOWER FELL AND THE
PERFECT BLUE SKY TURNED BLACK, I
I HAD KNOWN IN A LIFEBOAT GOING
TO NEW JERSEY LEAVING BEHIND MY
NEHBORHOOD BURIED IN DUSTY
WHITE AVALANCHE OF RUBBLE AND
DEBRIS.
WHEN I GOT TO NEW JERSEY A
FIREMAN'S DEEP V DIRECTED ME
TO JUMP.
I MADE IT OFF THE BOAT AND ONTO
THE DOCK WITHOUT FALLING INTO
THE HUDSON RIVER, BUT I LOST MY
SHOES AND WATCHED HELPLESSLY AS
THEY DRIFTED TOWARD THE SMOKEY
HORIZON.
WHILE I STOODTHER ANOTHER
FIREFIGHTER TOOK ME BY THE HAND
AND SILENTLY GUIDED ME THROUGH A
WHOLE IN A CHAIN LINK FENCE TO
AN OFFICE BUILDING WHERE MY
NEIGHBORS SOUGHT REFU.
WE LOOKED LIKE GHOSTS, COVERED
HEAD TO TOE IN DEBRING.
THE FIREFIGHTER HANDED ME A HOSE
SO I COULD CLEAN MY FACE AND
HAND.
I KNOW NOW THAT THE FIREFIGHTER
HAD FRIEND THAT HAD JUST DIED
MINUTES BEFORE, BUT IN THAT
SELFLESS MOMENT, HE TOOK MY HAND
AND TOOK THE TIME TO HELP ME GET
CLEANED UP
HE SHOWED ME WHAT ITAS LIKE TO
BE STRONG.
I'VE OFTEN WONDERED IF IN SE
SMALL WAY I SEE THE WORLD THE
WAY I DO TODAY BECAUSE OF THAT
FIREFIGHTER, BECAUSE I WITNESSED
THAT DAY THAT LOVE ANDOURAGE
TRUMP HATE AND DESTRUCTION.
WHILE MY NEIGHBORHOOD COLLAPSED
BEFORE MY EYES, MY STRONGEST
MEMORY IS STILL OF THAT ONE
FIREFIGHTER.
THE STORY OF 9/11 IS THAT TWO
PLANES HIT THE TOWERS, BUT THE
STORFOR ME IS THAT A
FIREFIGHTER HELD MY HAND.
WE, THE MEMBERS OF THE CLASS OF
2017, WERE FIRST GRADERS ON
SEPTEMBER 11 2001.
WE WERE HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS ON
APRIL 15, 2013 WHEN, FRESH O
RECEIVING OUR ACCEPE LETTERS
TO HARVARD, WE WOULD BE SUDDENLY
SOBERED BY THE BOSTON MARATHON
BOMBING.
THREE PEOPLE LOST THEIR LIVES,
MANY MORE WERE SERIOUSLY
INJURED.
FOUR DAYS LATER, CAMIDGE WAS
UNLOCKDOWN ASAW ENFORCEMENT
SEARCHED FORHE ROMAINI
SUSPECT.
STUDENTS HOLED UP IN THEIR DORM
ROOMS AS POLICE CARS PATROLLED
THE CITY.
VISTAS, THE THREE-DAY EVENT FOR
NEWLY ADMITTED STUDENT WAS TO BE
HOSTED THAT EKEND.
SOME OF US H
AND SPENT THE DAYT THE AIRPORT
IN LIMBO, WAITING.
IN THE END, SITAS WAS
CANCED.
HOWEVER, IN THE SPAN OF JUST A
FEW HOURS, HARVARD'S UPPER
CLASSMEN RALLIED TO CREATE A
VIRTUAL VISITAS AND CONNECTED TO
UNCERTAINTY, HARVARD STUDENTS .
RALLIED TO WELCOME THE CLASS OF
2017.
THE STORY OF THE2013 BOSTON
MARATHON IS THAT TWO BROTHERS
COMMITTED AN ACT OF TERROR THAT
KILLED A INJURED.
WAS TT BYSTANDERS RAN TOWARD Y
THE EXPLOSION TO SAVE LIVES?
THE STORY OF THE DAYS THAT
FOLLOWED IS THAT CAMBRIDGE WAS
UNLOCKDOWN ON THE WEEKEND THA
WAS SUPPOSED TO HAVE BEEN OUR
VISITAS.
T WHAT IF THE ULTIMATE STORY
WAS THAT HARVARD'S UPP
CLASSMEN CARED ENOUGH TO FIGURE
OUT ANOTHER WAY TO WELCOME US TO
HAD AND TO MAKE US FEEL AT
HOME?
GRADUATION DAY IS A CELEBRATION,
AN OCCASION TO LIFT GLASS, TO
MAKE A TOAST, TO ACKNOWLEDGE
ACCOMPLISH MANIES AND TO THANK
GOD WE ME IT THROUGH EXAMS.
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO SET AN
INTENTION FOR OURSELVES THAT
HONORS THE RESPONSIBILITY THAT
COMES WITH A HARVARD DEGREE.
WHEN THE UNIVERSE SHIFTED ON
SEPTEMBER 11th AND AGAIN ON
APRIL 15th, PPLE RAN TOWARD
THE EXPLOSION.
AND WHEN I LOOK AT A MAP AND
TRACE MY FINGER UP THE COAST,
ALL THE LINES AND BORDERS ON THE
MAP RUN TOGETHER.
AND WHEN WE FALL, WE ALWAYS COME
DOWN TOGETHER IN ONE PIECE.
I HAVE LEARNED THAT THE WORLD
CAN BE A SCARY PLACE, BUT I HAVE
ALSO LEARNED THAT IN THE FACE OF
WHO WILLE CHOOSE TO BE WHEN WE
ARE PRESENTED WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CARE ABOUT, TO
STAND WITH, TO SPEAK UP FOR, TO
GIVE UP SOMETHING OF OURSELVES
AS A SIMPLE ACT OF HUMANITY.
MANY OF US HAVE GONE TO BED IN
FEAR, FEAR OF DISCRIMINATION,
FEAR OF DEPORTATION, FEAR OF
WALLS AND BANS AND ROLLBACKS.
WE HAVE BEEN AFRAID.
AMONG US ARE THE COURAGEOUS.
I KNOW BECAUSE I'VE SEEN IT.
I'VE EATEN NEXT TO IT IN THE
DINING HALL.
I'VE STUDIED ACROSS FROM IT IN
E LIBRARY.
VE WALKED BYT IN HARV
YARD.
I KNOW THE MARK O COURAGE, AND
.
SO, AS WE WALK THROUGH THOSE
GATES ONE FINAL TIME AS
STUDENT
WEAPONS WISELY
LET COURAGE BE OUR DEFENSE
AGAINST COULD YOU XAGS OUR
DENSE AGAIN DESTRUCTION.
LET'S CHOOSE LOVE AS OUR
ULTIMATE DEFENSE AGAINST FEAR.
BECAUSE IN THE FACE OF FEAR LIES
THE GOLDEN OPPORTUNITY TO SHI
THE NARRATIVE BY SHOWING UP AS
SOMEONE WHO IS WILLING TO WALK
SIX-YEAR-OLD TO A SAFE PLACE
THROUGH A HOLE IN A CHAINLINK
FE
FENCE.
HERE, RIGHT NOW, LIES THE GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU, FORME, FOR
US TO BE THE ULTIMATE STORY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GRADUATE ENGLISH ADDRESS, HOW
TO BE BEWILDERED AT HARVARD.
CANDIDATE FOR THE DEGREE OF
MAST OF THEOLOGAL STUDIES,
WALTER SMELT III.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GET INTO HARVARD'S WIDENER
LIARY, YOU FIRST CLIMB A HUGE,
IMPOSING SET OF STEPS.
AFTER YOU DO THAT A YOU
FINALLY ENTER OUR MOST
MONUMON
MONUMENTAL TPLE OF LEARNING,
ANE
BECAUSE YOU'RE WIED.
THE WHOLE ORDEAL FEELS LIKE AN
ARCHITECT'SEAVY HANDED ATTEMPT
TO TEACH SOME LESSON, LIKE
KNOWLEDGE IS HARD.
ANYWAY.
ONCE YOU CATCH YOU BREATH, YOU
CLIMB THE SECOND STEP OF STEPS
TO FIND AT THE P A GUTENBERG
BIBLE.
AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW, THE
GUTENT
EXAMPLE OF A BOOK MADE WITH A
PRINTING PRESS, A REVOLUTIONARY
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY.
AS YOU PROBABLY DON'T KNOW, I
LOVE BOOKS.
THE MOST EXCITING PART OF COMING
TO HARVARD FOR ME WAS GETTING
THE LIBRARY CARD.
BECAUSE IF YOU LOVE BOOKS, THI
IS A GOOD PLACE TO BE.
IN FACT, I'LL TELLOU HOW BIG
OUR COLLECTION IS HERE.
THE LRARIANS AREN'T EVEN SURE
HOW MANY BOOKS WE HAVE THAT ARE
BOD IN HUMAN SKIN.
THEY THINK PBABLY JUST ONE,
BUT IF YOU DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
HUMAN-BOUND BOOKS ARE IN YOUR
LIBRARY, YOU HAVE A LOT OF
BOOKS.
OF COURSE, I DON'T JUST LOVE THE
PHYSICAL BOOKS, LOVE WHAT'S
INSIDE THEM.
IN PARTICULAR, LOVEITERATURE
AND SACRED TEXTS, LIKE THE
GUTENBERG BIBLE.
SO IN ORDER TO STUDY THEM, I
CAME TO HARVARD DIVINITY SCHOOL
WHICH TURNS 200 THIS YEAR!
AND I'M GLAD I DID, BAUSE IT
IS A MAGICAL, KOOKY PLACE WHERE
THE PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS FRIENDLY
AND OFTEN KNOW A LANGUAGE YOU
NEVER HEARD OF AND SOMETIMES
BUMP INTO BECAUSE THEY'RE DNG
WALKING DITATION, AND NO
MATTER
REMIND SOMEONE FROM A LINE O A
MYSTICAL POET ROMMY.
OF COURSE, EVERY PT OF THI
UNIVERSITY IS SPECL.
STUDENTS FROM HARVARD COLLEGE
AND OUR VARIOUS GRADUATE AND
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS ROUTINELY
BECOME LEADERS IN THEIR FIELDS.
NOBEL-WINNING PHICISTS,
EDUCATORS, BILLIONAIRES, POETS,
POLITICIANS, AND ON AND ON.
THOSE BOOKS I LOVE, MANY WERE
WRITTEN BY HARVARD GRADS, AND WE
CREATE NOT JUST WORKS OF
LITERATURE, BUT LAW BOOK MUSIC
BOOKS, THE ACCOUNT BOOKS OF
FORTUNE 500 COMPANIES.
AND FIGHT A FEW FORMERTUDENTS
HAVE HAD HISTORY BOOKS WRITTEN
ABOUT EM.
FOR INSTANCE, PRESIDENTS, AS
POLITICALLY DIFFERENT FROM ONE
ANOTHER AS GEORGE W. BUSH AND
BARACKOBAMA HOLD DEGREES FROM
THIS INSTITUTION.
I THINK GRADUATES HAVE A HABIT
FOR GOING ON TO THE RLD, FOR
OD AND FOR ILL, OFTEN AT THE
SAME TIME.
AND THAT'S WHERE THE DIVINITY
SCHOOL COMES IN.
BECAUSE THOUGH I SITS ON THE
EDGE OF CAMPUS, I BELIEVE IT IS
THEUNIVERSITY'S MORAL CEER.
IN THE CHEMISTRY LAB AND THE
MATH DEPARTMENT, THE GOAL IS TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS.
IN THE DIVINITY SCHOOL, PROBLEMS
ARE WRESTLED WITH, BUT THEY ARE
NEVER VANQUISHED, THAT'S BECAUSE
BEING HUMAN AND THEY NEED TO BE
CONFRONTED AGAIN BY EACH
GENERATION.
NO NEW TECHNOLOGY, NO PRINTING
PRESS OR APP IS GOING TO SETTLE
THE PROBLEM OF GREED OR DEATH OR
HATE.
AND AT THEIVINITY SCHOOL, WE
THINK ABOUT THESE PROBLEMS, AND
ABOUT HOW PEOPLE HAVE DEALT WITH
THEM THROUGH THE AGES AND HOW TO
DO WHAT RIGHT WE CAN I THE FACE
OF ALL THAT'S WRONG.
AS IT HAPPENS, THAT REMIND MEF
A LINE FROM ROOMY.
SELL YOUR CLEVERNESS AND BUY
BEWILDERMENT.
HARVARD GRAATES WILL CHANGE
THE WORLD ONE WAY OR ANOTHER,
BECAUSE WE'RE CLEVER, BUT WE
MUST BE MORE THAN THAT.
WE MUST BE WILLING TO BECOME
BEWILDERED, NEITHER APPROACHING
A PROBLEM ARROGANTLYSURE THAT
WE ALREADY KNOW THE ANSWER, NOR
THNG UP OUR HANDS AND
WALKING AWAY.
BECOMING BEWILDERED MEANS
ADMIING SOME PROBLEMS DON'T
VE .
IT MNS LEARNING FROM OUR
MIAKES, LEARNING FROM THE
OTHER, LEARNG WHAT IT IS WE
CAN'T LEARN.
TEACH US ABOUT.HINGS RESUMY CAN
ROOMY, AN IMMIGRANT FROM WHAT IS
NOW AFGHANISTAN TO WT IS NOW
TURKEY, AN IMMIGRANTROM THE
13th CENTURY TO OUR OWN, A
MUSLIM MYSTIC.
RUME H SOMETHING IMMSELY
VALUABLE TO TELL US, BUT WE HAVE
TO LISTEN REALLY HARD FOR IT
WITH HUMILITY AND FOR THE REST
OF O LIVES.
BE PROUD OF WHAT YOU'VE
ACCOMPLISHED HERE, BUT KW THAT
IT'S ONLY THE BEGINNING.
EARLIER I MENTIONED THE LESSON
OF THEIDENER STEPS.
WELL, AFTER
I'M SURE YOU'LL AGREE THAT
KNOWLEDGE I HARD, BUT WISDOM IS
EVEN HARDER.
WE'LL NEED BOTH OUT THERE,
WHATEVER OUR FIELD OF STUDY,
BECAUSE THIS WORLD IS COMPLEX
A
WEREN'T BILDERED SOMETIMES,
WE'RE DOING IT WRONG.
BUT WE'LL GO FORTH ANYWAY TO
CHANGED BY IT, TO WRITE OUR O E
BOOKS.
THOSE BOOKS MAY BE MADE OF PAPER
OR PUBLISHED DIGITALLY, OR WHAT
YOU LEAVE BEHIND MAY SIMY BE
THE LEGACY OF THE ACTS THAT ME
UP ALIFE.
REGARDLESS OF THE FORM, YOUR
BOOKS WILL BE GOOD BOOKS IF YOU
ARE WILLING TO BE BEWILDERED, IF
YOU TAKE ON THIS MESSY, TRAGIC,
[APPLAUSE]GOOD FAITH.RONT ITS
O THEY TELL ME OF A HOME FAR
BEYOND THE SKIES, THEY TELL ME
OF A HOME FAR AWAY,
AND THEY TELL ME OF A HOME WHERE
NO STORM-CLOUDS RISE:
O THEY TELL ME OF AN UNCLOUDED
DAY.
O THE LAND OF CLOUDLESS DAYS,
O THE LAND OF AN UNCLOUDED SKY,
O THEY TELL ME OF A HOME WHERE
NO STORM-CLOUDS RISE:
O THEY TELL ME OF AN UNCLOUDED
DAY.
O THEY TELL ME OF A HOME WHERE
MY FENDS HAVE GONE,
THEY TELL ME OF A LAND FAR
AWAY,
WHERE THE TREE OF LIFE IN
ETERNAL BLOOM
SHEDS ITS FRAGRANCE THROUGH
THE UNCLOUDED DAY.
THEY TELL ME OF A KING IN HIS
BEAURE,
THEY TELL ME THAT MINE EYES
SHALL BEHOLD
WHERE HE SITS ON A THRONE THAT
IS BRIGHT AS THE SUN
IN THE CITY THAT IS MADE OF
GOLD!
>> THESE ADDRESSES BY SELECTED
CANDIDATES FOR ORDINARY DEGREES
BEING END ED THE DEANS OF THE
PRESENT TO  FELLOWS AND  NOW
PRESIDENT IN THE FAVORERS
PRESENCE OF TH FEND HERE
ASSEMBLED.
THE CANDIDATES ON WHOM THE
VARIOUS AMIC DISTINCTIONS
ARE WI DUE CEREMONY TO BE
CONFERRED.
THE DEAN OF THE FACULTY OF ARTS
AND SCIENCES.
>> MADAM PRESIDENT, FELLOWS OF
HARVARD COLLEGE, MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD OF OVERSEERS, IN THE NAME
OF FACULTY OF ARTS AND SCIENCES
AND BY ITS AUTHORITY, I HAVTHE
HONOR TO REPORT ON FOUR GROUPS
CARVE DATES WHO WILL BE
FIRST, THE DEAN OF THE GRADUATED
SCOL OF ARTS AND SCIENCES WILL
PRESENT CANDIDATES FOR THE
DEGREE OF DOCTOR OFHILOSOPHY
AND THEN THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
ARTS.
NEXT, THE DEAN OF THE SCHOOL OF
ENGINEERING AND APPLIED SCIENCES
WILL PRESENT CAN DATES FOR THE
DEGREES OF MASTER OF SCIENCE AND
.
THIRD, THE DEAN OF CONTINUING
ATION AND UNIVERSITY
EXTENSION WILL PRESENT
CANDIDATES FOR THE DEGREES OF
ASSOCIATE IN ARTS, BACHELOR OF
LIBERAARTS,ND MASTER OF
LIBERAL TS INXTENSION
STUDIES.
FINALLY, AT THE CLOSE OF THESE
EXERCISES, THE SENIORS IN
HARVARD COLLEGE WHO ARE
NDIDATES FOR THE FIRST DEGREE
IN ARTS OR IN SCIENCE, WILL
STAND PROUDLY BEFORE YOU.
THEANDIDATES IN EAC OF THESE
GROUPS HAVE, BY VOTE OF THE
FACULTY,ULFILLED THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE DEGREES FOR
WHICH THEY ARE SEVERALLY
RECOMMENDED.
I SALUTE ALL OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS, TRUSTING THAT THEY
WILL FOREVER WISELY ENJOY THE
FREEDOMS THATHEIR EDUCATION
HAS GIVEN TO THEM WHILE BEARING
THE RESPONSIBILITIES THAT THE
ARNING DEMANDS OF THEM.
EACH OF THESE GROUPS WILL NOW BE
INTRODUCED TO YOU BY THE DEANS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PROGRAMS IN
WHICH THEY HAVE BEEN ENROLLED.
>> CANDIDATES FOR THE DEGREE OF
DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY WILL RISE.
>> THE PhDS, REALLY THE HIGHEST
HONOR OF THE UNIVERSITY, THE
TERMINAL DEGREE.
AND THE DEA OF THE GDUATED
SCHOOL.
>> T DEAN OF THE GRADUATED
SCHOOL OF ARTS AND SCIENCES.
>> MADAM ESIDENT, FELLOWS OF
HARVARD COLLEGE, MISTER
PRESIDENT, MEMBERS OF THE BOARD
OF OVERSEERS, AS THE DEAN OF
GRADUATED SCOL OF ARTS AND
SCIENCES- COME ON, SHALL I DO
THIS AGAIN?
THANK U FOR YOUR KINDNESS.
TO RETURN THE FAVOR, I WANT
DOUBLE-CHECK WITH EACH OF YOU IF
YOU REALLY, REALLY WANT THIS
DEGREE.
BECAUSE MANY OF YOU MAY REALIZE
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY YOUR LAST
CHANCE TO BE A HARVARD DROPOUT.
SO YOU WANT THE DEGREE?
THEN LET'S GET IT OVER WITH.
SCHOOL OF ARTS AND SCIENCES, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT TO YOU
THESE SCHOLARS, ALL OF WHOM HAVE
DEVOTED THEMSELVES TO THE
RIGOROUS PURSUIT OF ADVANCED
STUDY, HAVE ATAPED HIGH
DISTINCTION AND HAVE MADE
ORIGINALTRIBUTIONS TO
KNOWLEDGE IN THEIR SEVERAL
FIELDS OF SCHOLARSHIP.
>> BY BY VIRTUE OF THE AUTHORITY
DELEGATED TO ME, AND RECOGNIZING
YOUR HIGH ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENTS,
I CONFER ON YOU THE DEGREE OF
DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY, AND
WELCOME YOU TO THE ANCIENT AND
UNIVERSAL COMPANY OF SCHOLARS,
AND ENTRUST TO YOU -- WAIT, AIM
NOT DONE -- AND ENTRUST TO YOU
THE FREE INQUIRY-FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> I REMEMBER THIS MOMENT,
WELCOME TO THE ANCIENT A
UNIVERSAL COMPANY OF SCHOLARS,
MANY OF TM HAVE BEEN AT THIS
FOSIX YEARS, EIGHT YEARS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> YOU BE SEATED.
CANDIDATES FROM THE GRADUATE
THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF ARTS OR
WILL RISE.
>> AND THERE'S A MIXTURE HERE OF
STUDENTS.
>> THE DEAN OF THE GRADUATE
SCHOOL OF ARTS AND SCIENCES.
>> MAM PRESIDENT, FELLOWS OF
HARVARD COLLEG MISTER
PRESIDENT,EMBERS OF THE BOARD
OFOVERSEER AS THE DEAN OF THE
GRADTE SCHOOL OF ARTS AND
SCIENCES -- THANK YOU -- BUT I
WON'T REMIND YOU THAT TS IS
YOUR LAST CHANCE.
YOU CAN'T COME TO E GRADUATE
SCHOOL AS DO A DOCTORAL AND THEN
DROP OUT.
AS THE DEAN OF THE GRADUATE
SCHOOL OF ARTS AND SCIENCES, I
HAVE THE HON TO PRESENT TO YOU
THESE NDIDATES, ALL OF WHOM
VE COMPLETED A COMMENDABLE
STEP OF ADVANCED STUDY IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE DISCIPLINES.
>> BY BY VIRTUE OF THE AUTHORITY
DELEGATED TO ME  CONFER ON YOU
THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF ART AND
CERTIFY THAT YOU HAVE SURMOUNTED
WITH DISTINCTION THE FIRST STAGE
OF GRADUATE STUDY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THE DEAN WILL BE ON LEAVE
THIS YEAR AND WILL HAVE EMMA
DENCH AS THE INTERIM DEAN.
>> CANDIDATES FROM THE SCHOOL OF
ENGINEERING D APPLIED SCIENCES
FOR THE DEGREES OF MASTER OF
SCIENCE AND MASTER OF
ENGINEERING WILL RISE.
THE DEAN OF THE SCHOOL OF
ENGINEERING AND APPLIED
SCIENCES.
>> FRANK DO OUR NEST
SCHOOL.
MADAM PRESIDENT, FELLOWS
RVARD COLLEGE, MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD OF OVERSEERS, AS DEAN OF
THE SCHOO OF ENGINEERING AND
APPLIED SCIENC, I HAVE THE
HONOR TO PRESENTO YOU THESE
DEGREE CANDIDATES WHO HE
COMPLETED THE FIRST STEP OF
ADVANCED STUDY IN EINEERING
AND APPLIEDSCIENCES.
THEY STAND READY TO ADDRESS
SOCIETAL CHALLENGE THROUGH
FOUNDATION SCIENCE WITH
TRANSLATIONAL IMPACT.
>> BVIRTUE OF THE AUTHORITY
DEL
THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF SCIENCE
OR MASTER OF ENGINEERING, AND
CERTIFY THAT YOU HAVE SURMOUNTED
WITH DISTINCTION THE FIRST STAGE
OF GRADUATE STUDY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THIS SCHOOL HAS A SPECIAL
ORANGE AND GOLD-COLORED SET O
TIERS ON THEIR ROBES
>> CANDIDATES FOR THE DEGREES OF
ASSOCIATE IN ARTS, BACHELOR OF
LIBERAARTS IN EXTENSION
STUDIES WILL RISE.
THE DEAN OF CONTINUING EDUCATION
AND UNIVERSITY EXTENSION.
>> MADAM PRESIDENT, FLOWS OF
HARVARD COLLEGE, MISTER
PRESIDENT, MEMBERS OF THE BOARD
OFVERSEERS, AS DEAN OF
CONTINUING EDUCATION AND
UNIVERSITY EXTENSION, I HAVE THE
HONOR TO PRESE TO YOU THESE
STUDENTS, CANDIDATES FOR THE
DEGREE OF ASSOCIATE IN ARTS,
CHELOR OF LIBERAL ARTS AND
MASTER OF LIBERAL ARTS IN
EXTENSION STUDIES.
BY VIRTUE OF THE THORITY
DELEGATED TO ME, I CONFER ON YOU
THE DEGREE OF ASSOCIATE IN ARTS,
BACHELOR OF LIBERAL ARTS OR
MASTER OF LIBERAL ARTS IN
EXTENSION STUDIES, AND ADMIT YOU
TO THE FELLOWSHIP OF ECATED
PERSONS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>>DMITTED TO THE FELLOWSHIP OF
EDUCATED PERSONS EXTENSION COOL
IS ONE OF THE REAL --
>> IT'S REALLY AN INCREDIBLE
GROUP OF PEOPLE.
>> PSALM 79.
AGAIN TRADITIONAL.
>> THE DEAN OF THE FACULTYF
MED
MEDICINE.
>> MADAM PRESIDENT, FELLOWS OF
HARVARD COLLEGE, MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD OF OVERSEERS, IN THE NAME
OFHE FACULTY OF MEDICINE AND
BY ITS AUTHORITY, IT'S MY HONOR
TODAY TO REPORT THAT TWO GROUPS
OF CANDIDATES IN THE FIELDS OF
MEDICINE AND DENTAL MEDICINE
HAVE FULFILLED THE REQUIMENTS
OF THE FACULTY FOR THE DEGREES
FOR WHIC THEY ARE RECOMMENDED.
DEANS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PROGRAMS IN WHICH THEY ARE
ENROLLED.
>> CANDIDATES FOR THE DEGREES OF
DOCTOR OF DENTAL MEDICINE,
DOCTOR OF MEDICAL SCIENCES, AND
MASTER OF MEDICAL SCIENCES WILL
RISE.
THE DEAN OF THE SCHOO OF DENTAL
MEDICINE.
>> M PRESIDENT, FELLOWS OF
HARVARD COLLEGE, MISTER
PRESIDENT, MEMBERSF THE BOARD
OF OVERSEE, AS SEASON OF THE
SCHOOL OF DENTAL MEDICINE, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO PSENT TO YOU
TF
WHOM HAS DEVOTED FOUR YEARS TO
THE SDY OF DENTAL MEDICINE OR
AT LEAST THREE YEARS TO
POSTDOCTORAL STUDIES AIMED AT
IMPROVING HETH AND THE QUALITY
OF LIFE.
>> BY VIRTUE OF THE AUTHORIT
DELEGATED TO ME, I CONFER ON YOU
THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF DENTAL
MEDICINE, DOCTOR OF MICAL
SCIENCES, OR MASTER OF MEDICAL
SCIENCES, AND DECLARE THAT YOU
ARE QUALIFIED FOR PRAICE AND
RESEARCH IN A DEMANDING BRANCH
OF MEDICINE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> CANDIDATES FORK THE DEGREES
OF DOCTOR OF MEDICINE AND MASTER
OF MEDICAL SENCE WILL RISE. THE
DEGREES OF DOCTOR OF MEDICINE
AND MASTER OF MEDICAL SCIENCE
LL RISE.
THE DEAN FOR MEDICAL EDUCATION.
>> MADAM ESIDENT, FELLOWS OF
HARVARD COLLEGE, MISTER
ESIDENT, MEMBERS OTHE BOARD
OF OVERSEERS, AS DEAN FOR
MEDICAL EDUCATION, I HE THE
HONO TO PSENT TO YOU THESE
DEGREE CANDIDATES WHO HAVE
DEDICATED THEMSELVES TO THE
RELI OF HUMAN SUFFERING AND
PREPARED THEELVES WELL FOR A
LIFE OF LEARNING AND SERVICE IN
MEDICINE.
>> BY VIRTUE OF THE AUTHORITY
DELEGATED TO ME, I CONFER ONOU
THE DEGREE OF DOCTO OF MEDICINE
OR MASTER OF MEDICAL SCIENCE,
AND DECLARE THAT ASHYSICIANS
YOU ARE READY TO ENGAGE IN AN
HONORABLE AND MERCIFUL CALLING.
CONGRATULATIONS.
MASTER OF THEOLOGICAL STUDIES,
MASTER OF DIVINITY, MTER OF
THEOLOGY AND DOCTOR OF THEOLOGY
WILL RISE.
THE DEAN OF THE FACULTY OF
DIVINITY.
>> MADAM PRESIDENT, FELLOWS OF
RVARD COLLEGE, MISTER
PRESIDENT, MEMBERS OF THE BOARD
OF OVERSEERS, AS SEASON OF THE
FACULTY OF DIVINITY IN THIS OUR
BICENTENNIAL YEAR, I HAVE THE
HONOR TO PRESENT TO YOU THESE
DEGREE CANDIDATES, EACH OF WHOM
HAS DEVOTED TWO, THREE OR MORE
YEARS TO THEOLOGICAL AND
RELIGIOUS STUDIES IN PREPARATION
FOR CAREERS AS LEADERS IN
SERVICE.HIAND VOCATION OF
>> BY VIRTUE OF THE AUTHORITY
DELEGATED TO ME, I CONFER ON YOU
THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
THEOLOGICAL STUDIES, MASTER OF
DIVINITY, MASTER OF THEOLOGY, OR
DOCTOR OF THEOLOGY, AND DECLARE
THAT YOU ARE WELL PREPAD TO
FOSTER THE HEALTH AND VITALITY
OF COMMUNITIES OF FAITH, TO
FURTHER SCHOLARSHIP INELIGIOUS
STUDIES, AND TO HELP IN SHAPI
THE SHARED VALS OF THE BROADER
COUNITY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> CANDIDATES FOR THE DEGREES OF
DOCTOR OF LAW, MASTER OF LAWS
AND DOCTOR OF JURIDICAL SCIENCE
WILL RISE.
WITH DEEP APPRECIATION FOR HER
EIGHT YEARS OF LEADERSHIP OF
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL, I RECOGNIZE
THE DEAN OF THE FACULTY OF LAW.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU.
MADAM PRESIDENT, FELLOWS OF
HARVARD COLLEGE, MISTER
PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD OF OVSEERS, AS DEA OF
THE FACULTY OF LAW I HAVE THE
DISTINCT HONOR TO PRENT TO YOU
THIS BICENTENNIAL CLASS OF
EXTRAORDINARY AND DIVERSE
INDIVIDUALS, EACH OF WHOM HAS
MPLETED A DEGREE IN LEGAL
STUDIES TOWARD THE END O
VANCIN
THE RULE OF LAW.
>> BY VIRTUE OF THE AUTHORITY
DEGATED TO ME, I CONFER ON YOU
THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF LAW,
MASTER OF LAWS OR DOCTOR OF
JURIDICAL SCIENCE AND DECLARE
THAT YOU ARE READY -- YOU'RE
VERY READY OBVIOUSLY -- TO AID
IN THE SHAPING AND APPLICATION
OF THOSE WISE RESTRAINTS THAT
MAKE USFREE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> CANDIDATES FOR THE DEGREES OF
MASTER IN BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION AND DOCTOR OF
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION HAVE
RISEN.
THE DEAN OF THE FACULTY OF
BUSINESS ADMINISTRAON.
>> MADAM PRESIDENT, FELLOWS OF
HARVARD COLLEGE, MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD OF OVERSEERS, AS DEAN OF
THE FACULTY OF BUSISS, IT IS
MY GREAT HONOR TO PRESENTO YOU
THESE DEGREE CANDIDATES WHO HAVE
ADMINISTRATION AND PREPARED SS
THEMSELVES TO BECOME LEADERS WHO
WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THE
W.
>> BY VIRTUE OF THE AUTHORITY
DELEGATED TO ME, I CONFER ON YOU
THE DEGREE OF MASTER IN BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION, OR DOCTOR OF
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION AND
TESTIFY THAT YOURE READY TO
LE PEOPLE AND ORGANIZATIONS IN
ENTERPRISES THAT WILL SERVE
SOCIETY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> DEAN, PERHAPS THE FIRST, FROM
INDIA.
>> MADAM PRESIDT, AS A PROUD
PARENT I WOU ALSO LIKE TO GIVE
A SHOUT OUT TO MY DAUGHTER.
[APPLAUSE]
>> CANDIDATES FOR THE SEVERAL
DEGRS INARCHITECTURE,
LANDSCE ARCHITECTURE, URBAN
PLANNING AND DESIGN WILL RISE.
E DEAN OF THE FACULTY OF
DESIGN.
>> AND HERE AGAIN, A SENSE OF
THE INTERNATIONAL CONVENTIONS OF
HARVARD ADMINISTRATION.
>> MADAM PRESIDENT, FELLOWS OF
HARVARD LLEGE, MISTER
PRESIDENT, MEMBERS OF THE BOD
OF OVERSEERS, AS DEAN OF THE
FACULTY OF DESIGN, I HAVE THE
HONOR TO PRESENT TO YOU THESE
STUDENTS, EACH OF WHOM H
QUALIFIED FOR A MASTER'S DEGREE
IN ARCHITECTURE, LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECTURE, URBAN DESIGN,
URBAN PLANNING, OR DESIGN
STUDIES, OR FOR THE DEGREE OF
DOCTOR OF DESIGN.
>> BY VIRTUE OF THE AUTHORITY
DELEGATED TO ME, I CONFER ON YOU
THE DEGREE FOR WCH YOU HAVE
QUALIFIED, AND DECLARE YOUR
COMPETENCE TO LEAD IN SHAPING
THE SPACES IN WHICH WE LIVE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> CANDIDATES FORHE SEVERAL
DEGREES IN PUBLIC HEAL WILL
RISE.
>> AND WE HAVE OUREW DEAN OF
PUBLIC TH, MICHELE WILLIAMS.
>> THE DEAN OF THE FACULTY OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
>> DEAR MADAM PRESIDENT, FELLOWS
OF HARVARD COLLEGE, MISTER
PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD OF OVERSEERS, AS A
FRESHMAN DEAN OF THE FACULTY OF
PUBLIC HEALTH, I HAVE THE GREAT
HONOR TO PRESENT TO YOU THESE
STUDENTSEACH OF WHOM HAVE
QUALIFIED FOR A MASTER'S DEGREE
OR A DOCTOR'S DEGREE TO PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP, ADVANCE KNOWLEDGE,
.
>>Y VIRTUE OF THE AUTHORITY
DELEGATED TO ME, I CONFER ON YOU
THE DEGREES IN PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
WHICH YOUR STUDIES HAVE
QUALIFIED YOU, AND DECLARE THAT
YOU ARE WELL PREPARED TO
GENERATE AND UTILIZE KNOWLEDGE
TO IMPROVE HEALTH THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD.
CONGRATUTIONS.
>>DIDATES FOR THE DEGREES OF
DOCTOR OF EDUCION,  DOCTOR OF
U
OF EDUCATION WILL RISE.
>>HEY ARE MAKING EVEN MORE
NOISE THAN THE LAW SCHOOL OR THE
BUSINESS SCHOOL.
E ED SCHOOLEALLY HAS A LOT
OF SPIRIT.
>> THEEAN OF THE FACULTY OF
EDUCATION.
>>HIS IS JIM AN, DEAN FOR
THE PAST FEW YEARS.
>> MADAM PRESIDENT, FELLOWS OF
HARVARD COLLEGE, MISTER
PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD OF OVERSEERS -- OKAY.
AS DEAN OF THEULTY OF
EDUCATION I HAVE THE HONOR TO
PRESENT TO YOU THESE DEGREE
CANDIDATES WHO WILL CHANGE THE
WORLD THROUGH EDUCATION.
>> BY VIRTUE OF THE AUTHORITY
GATED TO ME, I CONFER ON YOU
E MASTER'S OR DOCTOR'S DEGREE
IN EDUCATION, AND DECLARE THAT
YOU ARE WELL PREPAREDO ADVANCE
LEARNING TO CHANGE THE WORLD.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> ONE MORE PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL
BEFORE THE COLLEGE.
>> CANDIDATES FOR THE DEGREES OF
MASTER IN PUBLIC ADMINISTRATION,
MASTER IN PLIC ADMINISTRATION
INNTERNATIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
>> THESE ARE THE KENNEDY SCHOOL
STUDENTS HOLDING THE GLOBES,
DESTINED FOR CAREERS IN PUBLIC
SERVE.
>> ONE MORREE TO GO, GUYS.
AND MASTER IN PUBLIC POLICY WILL
RISE.
THE DEAN OF THE FACULTY OF
GOVERNMENT.
>> THIS IS DOUG ELMENDORF FORMER
HEAD OF THE CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET
OFFICE.
>> MADAM PRESIDEN FELLOWS OF
HARVARD COLLEGE, MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD OF OVERSEERS, AS DEAN OF
THE FACULTY OF GOVERNMENT, I
HAVE THE GREAT HONOR TO PRESENT
TO YOU THESE DEGREE CANDIDATES,
EACH OF WHOM HAS QUALIFIED TO
PROVIDE LEADERSHIP IN PUBLIC
SERVICE.
>> BY VIRTUE OF THE AUTHORITY
DELEGATED TO ME, I CONFER ON YOU
STUDIES HAVE QUALIFIED YOU, AND
TESTIFY THAT YOU A WELL
PREPARED TO OFFER LDERSHIP IN
THE QUT FOR ENLIGHTED PUBLIC
POLICY AND EFFECTIVE PUBLIC
SERVICE THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
NGRATULATIONS.
>> AND NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE
UNDERGRADUATES.
>> BUT FIRST THE WORLD PREMIERE
OF"TO THE RIVER CHARLES."
RIVER! THAT IN SILENCE WINDEST
THROUGH THE MEADOWS, BRIGHT AND
RIVER! AT IN SILENCE WINDEST
FREE,
TILL AT LENGTH THY REST THOU
FINDEST
IN THE BOSOM OF E SEA!
FOUR LONG YRS OF MINGLED
FEELING,
HALF IN RES AND HALF IN
STFE,
I HAVE SEEN THY WATERS
STEALING
ONWARD, LIKE THE STREAM OF
LIFE.
THOU HAST TAUGHT ME, SILENT
RIVER!
MANY A LESSON, DEEP AND LONG;
;
IAN GIVE THEE BUT A SONG
>> CANDIDATES FOR THE DEGREE OF
BACHELOR OF ARTS OR OF SCIENCE
WILL RISE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THERE THEY ARE, SOME 1,600 OF
THEM.
>> AND OF COURSE THE SUMMA CUM
LAUDE GRADUATES ASSEMBLED HERE,
ONES THE DAUGHTER OF A FORMER
RHODES SCHOLAR FROM HARVARD WHO
WAS IN THE CLASS OF 1976.
>> THERE ARE CHOSEN
REPRESENTATIVES TOGETHER WITH
CANDIDATES FOR THOSE DEGREES
SUMMA CUM LAUDE WILLRAW NEAR.
>> THE CHOSEN REPRESENTATIVES
ARE THE MEMBERS OF THE CLASS
MARSHA
>> THE DEAN OF HARVARD COLLEGE.
>> AND DREFAUST WILL ACTUALLY
GO AND GREET SOME OF THE SUMMAS.
HARVARD COLLEGE, MISTER
PRIDENT AND MEMBERS OF THE
BOAROF OVERSEERS, AS DEAN OF
HARVARD COLLEGE I HAVE THE HON
TO PRESENT TO YOU THESE
STUDENTS, EACH OF WHOM H
FULFILLED THE FACULTY'S
REQUIRENTS FOR THE FIRST
DEGR IN ART OR IN SCIENCE.
EACH CANDIDATE STANDS READY TO
VANCE KNOWLEDGE, TO PROMOTE
UNDERSTANDING, AND TO SERVE
SOCIETY.
>> BY VIRTUE OF THE AUTHORITY
DELEGATED TO ME, I CONFER ON YOU
THE FIRST DEGREE IN ARTS OR IN
SCIENCE AND ADMIT YOU TO THE
FELLOWSHIP O EDUCATED PERSONS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> AND SHE NOW LEAVES THAT CHAIR
FOR T FIRST TIME AND COME AND
GREAT AND SHAKE HANDS WITH SOME
OF THOSE WHO HAVE GRADUAD.
>> THEY ARE STUDENTS NO MORE,
THEY ARE ALUMNI.
>> THE NUMBER OF SUMMA CUM LAUDE
STUDENTS IS LIMITED IN CLASS,
AND VED BY THE FACULTY JUST
THIS PAST MONDAY AFTERNOON.
>> THEY RLLY HAVE TO HAVE
EXTREME ACHIEVEMEN
>> BOTH BY THEIR DEPARTMENT
THROUGH A SUMMA THESIS, AND
CERTAINLY BY THEIR OVERALL GRADE
POINT AVERAGE.
THE TOP SCHARS IN THIS CLASS,
THERE WERE SEVEN OF THEM GIVEN
THAT TOP SCHOLAR AWARD, HAD A
GRADE POINT 0 ALL THE WAY
THROUGH.
>> BY VIRTUE OF THE AUTHORITY
DELEGATED  ME BY THE T
GOVERNING BOARDS, I NOW CONFER
THFOLLOWING HONORARY DEGREES.
THE PROVOSTILL INTRODUCE THE
CANDIDATES.
>> SHE HAS BEEN CALLED EQUAL
PARTS MOTHER TERESA AND RAMBO.
ONE OF SOMALIA'S MOST REVERED
FIGURES, SHE EMBODIES A RARE
COMBINATION OF COMPASSN AND
COURE.
IN THEACE OF DANGER AND
DESPAIR, AS A CHILD IN MOGADISHU
SHE WATCHED HER PREGNT MOTHER
DIE BEFORE HER EYES, AND SHE
RESOLVED TO BECOME A PHYSICIAN.
LIVING IN POVERTY, LEFT TO RAISE
FOUR SISTERS, SHE WON A
SCHOLARN
KIEV.
SHE LATER RETURNED TO HER
HOMELAND, OBTAINED A LAW DEGREE,
ANDN 1983 FOUNDED A ONE-ROOM
HEALTH CLINIC OUTSIDE MOGADISHU.
WITHIN A DECADE, CHAOS CAME TO
SOMALIA AS H COUNTRY WAS
RAVAGED BY CIL WAR, DROUGHT,
FAMINE AND DISEASE.
HER SMALL CLINIC GREW INT A
SPRAWLING VILLAGE.
A REFUGE FOR TENS OF THOANDS
OF PEOPLE SEEKING SAFETY,
SUSTENANCE AND A SEMBLANCE OF
ORDER IN A DISORDERED WORLD.
THE VILLAGE CAME TO BARE HER
NAME, AND IN TIME IT BECAME A
TARG FOR MILITANTS DETERMINED
TO SPREAD VLENCE AND FEAR.
SH DEFIED THEIR DEMANDS.
SHE WITHSTOOD THEIR ATTACKS,
FACED WITH CONTINUING THREATS,
SHE CARRIED ON.
AS SOM CONTINUES TO SUFFER,
HERVILLE LELING CONTINUES TO
OFFER A H FOR PEOPLE IN
DESPERATE NEED
SHE INSISTS THAT THEVILLE
LARGERS OBEY A SIMPLE RULE: TO
LIVE THERE, YOU ARE SIMPLY A
SOMALI, NOT A MEMBER OF A CLAN.
WITH HER TWO DAUGHTERS, BOTH
DOCTORS, SHE STILL WORKS
ATTENTION TO HER COUNTRY'S D'S
PLIGHT, AND TO PROVIDE TENS OF
THOUSANDS SOMALIS WITH SHELTER
AND HEALTH CARE, FOOD AND
EDUCATION, PEACE AND HOPE.
WITH DEEP ADMIRATION, WE HONOR
DR. HAWA ABDI.
>> EXTRAORDINARY WOMAN AND
SOMEONE WHO HAS MADE AN ENORMOUS
DIFFENCE IN SOMALIA.
SHE IS ATTENDED IN THE BACK BY
JENNIFER MEANING, WHO IS FROM
THE SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH,
HEAD OF THE FXB CENTER.
>> CONFRONTING THE RAVAGES OF
WAR AND FAMINE, OFFERING HOPE TO
THOSE IN DIRE NEED, SHE FACES
THE FORCENESS OF DARKNESS AND
KEEPS THE FLAMES THE LIGHT OF
HOPE.
HAWABDI DIBLAWE, DOCTOR OF
LAWS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> SOME CAREERS ARE SO
REMARKABLY FULL AND VARIED THAT
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THEY'RE THE
SO IT  WITH OUR NEXTIDUAL.
DISTINGUISHED GUEST, A NIVE OF
HATTIESBURG, MISSISSIPPI, WHO
EW UP DEEP IN THE SEGREGATE
SOUTH AND WHOSE EARLY PROMISE IN
MATHEMATICS LED HIM TO COLLEGE
STRAIGHT FROM THE TENTH GRADE.
OFESSORF PHYSICS ANDEAN OF
THE C
TEACHERS O SCIENCE PROGRAM,
VICE PRESIDENT FOR RESEARCH AT
THE UNIVERSY OF CH
CO-FOUNDER OF THE NATIONAL
SOCIETY OF BLACK PHYSIC,
DIRECTOR OF THE OREGON NATIOL
LABORATORY, DIRECTOR OF T
NATIONAL SCIENCE FOUNDATION,
PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATN FOR THE ADVANCEMENT
OF SCIENCE, OCCUPANT OF THE
EXALTED POSITION OF PROVO AT
THE UNIVERSITY OFCALIFORNIA,
OF HIS ALMA MATER, MOREHOUSEARS
COLLE, WHOSE CENTER FOR
LEADERSHIP NOW BRS HIS NAME,
CH
CHAIR OF THE GIANT MAGELLAN
TELESCOPPROJECT, AND A
TESTAMT TO HIS LEADERSHIP WELL
BEYOND THE SCIENCES, PRESIDENT
AND NOW CHANCELLOR OF THE SCHOOL
OF THE ART INSTITUTE OF CHICAGO.
WE PHYSICISTS LIKE TO BELIEVE WE
CAN DAMN NEAR ANYTHING, HE ONCE
SAID, A FITTING OBSERVATION FROM
A PHYSICIST WHO HAS DONE JUST
THAT.
HE IS ESPECIALLY ADMIRED FOR HIS
DEEPEDICATION TO PROMOTING
SCIENTIC LITERACY AND
INNOVATIVEEDUCATION, TO
ADVANCINTHE ART OF NTORING,
TO EASING THE PH FROM
DISCOVERY TO INVENTION AND TO
CREATING OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
UNDERREPRESENTED.
WE PROUD HONOR WALTER MASSEY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> A EXTRAORDINARY CAREER FROM
MATHEMATIN THE SOUTH TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ROLES I
IVERSITY OF CHICAGO, BROWN,
MOREHOUSE.
>> TRAVERSING TWO CULN
ACADEMIC LEADER, ADVANCING
USEFUL KNOWLEDGE AS A CITIZEN OF
SCIENCE, A SENDID MENTOR
ALWA POISED TO ON DOORS FOR
OTHERS, A MODEL MAN OF
MOREHOUSE, STEADFAST, HONEST AND
TRUE, WALTER E. MASSEY, DOCTOR
OF LAWS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> FEW ACADEMIC DISCIPLINES HAVE
SHAPED OUR TIMESORE THAN
COMPUTER SCIENCE.
D FEW INDIVIDUALS HAVE SHAPED
COMPUTER SCIENCE MORE THAN THE
HARVARD COLLEAGUE WE HONOR NEXT.
THE SON OF A RABBI, HE MOVED
WITH HIS FAMILY FROM NAZI
GERMANY TO PALESTINE AS A CHILD.
ONE DAY, AT AGE 11, HE FOUND
HIMSELF IN THE COMPANY OF OLDER
BOYS, STRUGGLING WITH A GEOMETRY
PROBLEM.
THEY COULDN'T SOLVE IT.
HE DID.
HIS EARLY LOVE OF MATHEMATICS
LED HIM TO PRINCETON FOR A PhD,
AND THEN TO IBM.
THERE HE CO-WROTE A PAPER ON THE
SUBJECT OF FINITE ATOMITA.
THE PAPER WAS A CRUCIAL EARLY
S
DESIGN OF COMPUTER SYSTEMS, AND
A KEY TO HIS EARNING THE MOST
PRESTIGIOUS PRIZE IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE, THE TOING AWARD.
OVER HIS LONG CAREER, HE HAS
MAY FOUNDATIONAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO HIS FIELD.
HE HAS EXPLORED T LIMITS OF
WHAT CAN AND CANNOT BE COMPUTED.
HE HAS CREATED SOFTWARE THAT IS
USED TO SPREAD INFORMATION
ROSS
AND NETWORKS.
HE HAS PIONEERED THE STUDY OF
RANDOMIZED ALGORITHMS, INCLUDING
THE TEST OF WHETHER A NUMBER IS
PRIME.
HE HASONE MUCH TO SHAPE THE
MODERN FIELD OF CRYPTOGRAPHY,
THE BASIS OF SECURE
COMMUNICION IN THE INTERNET
AGE.
AND AS A MEMBER OF THE HARVARD
FACULTY SINCE 1981, HE HAS HAD A
DEVELOPMENT OF COMPUTER SCIENCE
AT THIS UNIVERSITY AND AROUND
THE WORLD.
WE PROUDLY WELCOME HARVARD'S
THOMAS J.ATSON SENIOR RESEARCH
PROFESSOR OF COMPUTER SCIENCE
AND THE AERT EINSTEI
PROFESSOR EMERITUS OF
MATHEMATIE
AT HIS ALMA MATER, THE HEBREW
UNIVERSITY IN JERUSALEM, MICHAEL
RABIN.
[APPLAUSE]
>> PRIME HIGH CAPACITY HARD
DRIVE OF HARVARD COMTER
SCIENCE WHOSE IMPACT IS AS
ININCALCULABLE.
DR. MICHRABIN, DOC OF
SCIENCE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> AT AGE FIVE, AT HER QUAKER
SCHOOL IN YORK, ENGLAND, SHE
MADE HER STAGE DEBUT IN THE
FEATURED ROLE OF A SNL.
AT THE TIME, THE LONDON THEATER
CRITICS TOOK LITTLE NOTICE OF
THE IMPROVISATIONAL SLITTERING
THAT DISTINGSHED HER ELY
DEBU
BUT BY HER EARLY 20s, THE
THEATER WORLD HAD FOUND INER A
RADIANT NEW STAR, AND BY 2010, A
PUBLIC POLL IN BRIIN NAMED HER
THE GREATEST STAGE ACTOR OF ALL
TIME.
[APPLAE]
>> ON BOTH STAGE AND SCREEN, SHE
HAS BROUGHT TO LIFE AN INFINITE
VARIETY OF ROLES, FROM OPHELIA
TO IRIS MURDOCH,ROM CABARETS,
SALLY BOWLS, TO CLEOPATRA, FROM
LADY BRATINAL TO LADY MCBETH
FROM TATANIA, QUEEN OF THE
RRIES TO ELIZABETH AND
VICTORIA, QUEEN OF ENGLAND,
FROM THE FAIR JULIET, MEO'S
BELOVED, TO THE FORMIDABLE M,
THE BOSS OF JAMES BOND.
SHE HAS WON EIGHT OLIVIA AWARDS
BRITISH STAGE, MORE THAN ANY
EVER.
SHE HAS WONEN AWARDS FROM THE
BRITISH ACADEMY OF FILM AND
TELEVISION ARTS, SIX FOR THE BIG
SCREEN, FOUR FOR THE SMALL.
AS ONE COLLEAGUE WRITES, THE
WRETCHED WOMAS NO FAULTS,
EITHER PERSONALLY NOR
PROFESSIONALLY.
IARVEL AT THE SUBTLY AND IN
SOME WAYS THE SIMPLICITY OF HER
ACTING.
WHAT SHE DOES SEEMS TO BE THE
RIGHT THING AND THE ONLY THING
TO DO AT THE MOMENT SHE DOES IT.
ON HER WRIST SHE SPORTS A
BIRTHDAY GIFT FROM HER HTER,
A TATTOO WITH THE WORDS
"KARPE DIEM."
SHE HAS CONTINUED TO CEASE EACH
DAY ANDO SEIZE THE RAPT
ATTENTION OF AUDIENCES FROM BOTH
.
WEONOR DAME JUDI DENCH.
[APPLAUSE]
>> EXTRAORDINARY ACTRESS.
>> WITHAIR TITANIA'S POWERS OF
ENCHANTMENT AND CLEOPATRA'S MREN
DUED O CHARMS, A VENERATED
QUEEN OF SCREEN AND THEATER WITH
WHOM WE FEEL A FOND FAMILIAL
BOND, DAME JUDI DENCH, DOCTOR OF
ARTS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> AS A YOUNG EAGLE SCOUT
GROWING UP IN DENVER, HE DREAMED
BUT URGED BY A HIGH SCHOOL .
TEHER HE MOVED EAST TO ATTEND
WHAT IS STILL REGARDED AS OUR
HIGHEST INSTITUTION OF HIGHER
LEARNING, AT LEAST OF
UNIVERSITIES LOCATED A FEW MES
WEST OF THE NEW JERSEY TURNPIKE.
WITH HIS PAIR OF PRINCON
DEGREES, HE BUILT A CAREER AS
ONE OF HIS GENERATI'S MOST
SUCCESSFUL EXECUTIVES, RISING TO
BECO THE INFENTIAL CHAIRMAN
AND CEOF LOCKHEED-MARTIN, A
GLOBAL LEADER IN AEROSPACE AND
TECHNOLOGY.
A VETAN OF TWO STINTS IN THE
PENTAGON, HE HAS BEEN A STRONG
EXPONENT OF PUBLIC SERVI IN
THE NATIONAL INTEREST.
LONG A PROMINENT FIGURE IN
POLICY CIRCLES, HE HAS BEEN
CALLED THE MOST INFLUENTIAL
NON-SCIENTIST IN U.S. SCIENCE.
AS CHAIR OF FEDERAL COUNCS AND
COMMITTEES, HE HAS PLAYED
LEADING ROOM IN SHAPING THE U.S.
SPACE PROGRAM.
AS CHAIR OF A NATIONAL ACEMY'S
COMMISSION THAT PRODUCED THE
LANDMARK REPORT RING AVE THE
GATHERING STORM, HE HAS
FORCEFULLY URGED SUPPORT FOR
BASIC SCIENCE RESEARCH AS A WELL
SPRING OF INNOVATION AND
PROSPERITY
AS A TRUSTEE AT PRINCETON,
M.I.T., THE UNIVERSITY OF
MARYLAND, AND JOHNS HOPKINS, HE
HAS BEEN A STAUNCH ADVOCATE FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION.
CROSS, AUTHOR OF FOUR BOOKS AND
AN AVID OUTDOORS MAN WHO HAS
VENTURED TO BOTH THE NORTH AND
SOUTH POLES,EAS RECEIVED THE
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT HIGHEST
CIVILIAN HONOR FIVE TIMES, AS
WELL AS THE NATIONAL MEDAL OF
TECHNOLOGY.
WE HONOR NORMAN AUGUSTINE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> REALLY A GIANT CHAMPION OF
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY.
THAT AUGUSTINE REPORT REALLY
STILL A MANIFESTO-
>>ROMISE OF THE ENDLESS
FRONTIER, DEVED TO SCIENCE IN
THE NATION'S ICE, A TIGER OF
INDUSTRY WITH A ZEST FOR
ADVENT
ROCKETS, HE HAS AN EYE FORHAT
WILL FLY.
NORMAN AUGUSTINE, DOCTOR OF
WS.
[APPLAUS
>> HE'S ALS BEEN TO BOTH T
NORTH AND SOUTH POLE I LEARNED
LASTNIGHT.
>> IN INTRODUCING OUR NEXT
GUEST, CELEBRATED COMPOSURE OF
MUSIC SCORES AND CONDUCTOR
LAUREATE OF THE BOSTON POPS,
MUSIC SEEMS MORE FITNG THAN
WORDS.
A LONG TIME AGON A GALAXY FAR,
FAR WAY..
#
[APPLAUSE]
>>ERFORMING THIS MEDLEY OF
GREAT TUNES OF JOHN WILLIAMS.
>> WE HONOR THE MAESTRO WHO HAS
WRTEN MUSIC FOR MORE THAN 100
MOVIES, WHO HAS BEEN NOMINED
FOR MORECADEMY AWARDS THAN ANY
LIVINGBEING, TERRESTRIAL OR
EXTRA, AND WHOM HAS COLLABORATOR
STEVEN SPIELBERG CALLS ONE OF
THE GREAT STORY TELLERS OF ALL
TIME, JOHN WILLIAMS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> OTT ONLYN BOSTON BUT
ARND THE COUNTRY, HERALDED FOR
THEEARS HE AT THE BOSTON
POPS AS LL.
>> THE SUPERMAN OUSIC FOR THE
MOVIES WHOSE SCORES OF SCORES
PROPEL GREAT STORIES SKYWARD.
HIS MELODIES DWELLEEP INSIDE
OUR MEMORIES, HIS HARMONIES
INDUCE OUR HEARTS TO SOAR.
JOHN WILLIAMS, DOCTOR OF MUSIC.
[APPLAUS
>> WHENHE WAS FOUR, SHE GURED O
AND THEN RITING THEM FORER
MOTHER HAD THE HAPPY RESULT OF
POSTPONING HER BEDTIME.
SHE STILL THINKS BACK FONDLY ON
HE ELIESTOPUS.
ZIP, ZIP THROUGH THE AIR COMES A
FEARFUL BEAR, HIS NAME IS
LIGHTENING, AND WHEN HE COMES,
YOU CAN SEE THE WHOLE SKY
BRIGHTENING.
HOW AND SITODAY.
FR HLY FASCINATION WITH
WORDS, SPRING THE LIFELONG LOVE
OF LITERATURE, AND A CAREER AS A
GROUND-BREAKING LITERARY CRITIC
AND DISTINGUISHED POET A
ESSAYIST.
HE 1979 BOOK, THE MAD WOMAN IN
THE ATTIC,CO-HITTER WITH SUSAN
GUBAR, HAS BEEN STALLED A
STUNNING MOMENT F LITERARY
CRITICISM.
AS ONE REVIEWER SAID, IT OFFERED
A BOLD, NEW INTERPRETATION OF
THE GREAT 19th CENTURYOMEN
NOVELISTS PRESENTING THE FIRST
PERVASIVEE FOR THE EXISTENCE
OF A DISTINCY FEMALE
IMAGINATION.
SHE AND HER LONGIME
COLLABORATOR, THEN CO-WROTE THE
NDMARK THREE VOLUME SERIES
"NO-MAN'S-LAND"XPLORING THE
WORK OF 20th CENTURY WOMEN
WRITERS AND PRODUCING ANOTHER
CLASSIC OF FEMINIST LITERARY
STUDIES.
SHE IS NOT JUST A PIONEERING
CRITIC, BUT ALSO AN
AWARD-WINNING POET, ACCLAIM
FOR POEMS THAT, AS ONE COLLEAGUE
PUT IT, ARE BEAUTIFULLY SITUATED
ATHE INTERSECTIO OF CRAFT AND
FEELIN
SHE HAS ALSO WRITTEN WITH
EXTRAORDINARY INSIGHT ABOUT
DEATH AND THE WAYS WEGRIEVE.
HER BOOK, EATH'S DOOR," A
RICHLY TEXTURED CONTEMPLATION OF
MORTALITY HAS BEEN CALLED A
SUPERB ACHIEVE MANY THAT CARRIES
US GENTLY BUT POWEULLY TOWARD
UNDERSTANDING.
WE HONOR ONE OF THE LEADING
GENERATION, DISTINGUISHED
PROFESSOR EMERITA OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS,
SANDRA GILBERT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> CASTING NOVEL LIGHT WHERE
SHADOWS SHROUDED WOMEN'S
WRITING, CRAFTING POIGNANT POEMS
THAT BOTH SPIRIT ANDENLIGHTEN,
PIONEER OF FEMINIST STUDIES
FOR WHOM THEERSONAL IS THE
POLITICAL AS WELL AS THE
POETICAL.
SANDRA GILBERT, DOCTOR OF LAWS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> OUR NEXT GUEST GREW UP IN
BEIRUT DURING WHAT SHE CALLS ITS
MOST WONDERFUL DAYS.
SHE WANTED TODY SHAKES HERE,
BUT HER MOTHER URGED SCIENCE
INSTEAD.
SHE STUDIED BIOLOGY AT THE
AMERICAN UNIVERSITY IN BEIRUT,
THEN STARTED MEDICAL SCHOOL
THERE.
SOON, CIVIL WAR ENGULFED THE
CITY.
BOMBS FELL ALL AROUND.
R HOUSE WAS DAMAGED.
HER BROTHER WAS INJURED BY
SHRAPNEL.
SHE NT TO LIVE WIT RELATIVES
IN TEXAS, HOPING TO RETURN HOME
SOON, BUT THE WAR IN LEBANON
WORSEN.
SHE MED TO NASHVILLE, AND
FINISHED HER STUDIES AT MAHARE
DICAL COLLEGE.
HAVING RETURNE TO TEXAS, NOW AT
PEDIATRIC CARDIOLOGIST, BUT SHE
BY CHANCE, WITHIN TWO WEEKS, SHE
SAW TWO YOUNG PATIENTSH A
DEVASTATING, YET PRLY
UNDERSTOOD DISEASE CALLED
RHETT'S SYNDROME, WHICH SHE ONLY
HEARD ABOUT RECENTLY.
SHE PLUNGED INTO RESEARCH MOVED
BY THEIR PLIGHT.
BEFORE LONG, SHE BECAME A
LEADING EXPERT ON THE
DEGENERATIVE DISORDER KNOWN AS
SPINAL CEREBELLAR ATAXIA TYPE I.
SHE WENT ON TO DISCOVER THE
ELUSIVE GENE ASSOCIAD WITH
RHETT'S NDROME, AND SHE BUILT
A CAREER AS A PREEMENT
AUTHORITY ON THE GENETIC CAUSES
AND BIOLOGICAL MECNISMS OF
NEUROLOGICAL DISEES.
HER WORK HOL PROMISE TO ADVANCE
UNDERSTANDING OF AUTISM,
PARKINSON'S, ALZHEIMER'S, AND
OTHER DISEASES OF THE CENTRAL
NERVOUS SYSTEM, AND ITAS HAD A
WIDER IMPACT ON AILMES FROM
HEARING LOSS TO COLON CANCER.
RECIPIENT OF AN ALPHABET IN
HONORS IN SCIENCE AND MEDICINE,
INVESTIGATOR, EDUCATOR, AND
NTOR.
WE HONOR FROM BAYLOR COLLEGE OF
MEDICINE AND THE HOWARD HUGHES
MEDICAL INSTUTE, HUDA ZOGHBI.
[APPLAUSE]
>> FROM DARKLESS YOUNG WOMAN WHO
NEVER LOST NERVE, TO EMINENT
EXPERT ON THE NERVOUS SYSTEM'S
WORKINGS, SHE PATIELY
TRANSLATES THE LANGUAGE OF LIFE
THAT PIENTS MIGHT REALIZE
THE PROMISE OF LIFE.
HUDA ZOGHBI, DOCTOR OF SCIENCE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> HE HAS FACED DOWN VIRULENT
RACISM WHILE BOXING HIS WAY TO
THE HEAVYWEIGHT TITLE
HE HAS RENRED HEROIC SERVICE
IN THE VENETIAN ARMY THEN
SUCCUM TREACHER
HE HAS EXPERIENCED THE GLORY OF
BASEBALL STARDOM AND T
TRAVAILS OF A HARD LIFE THAT
FOLLOW.
HE HAS STH TO LORE DUKE --
LUKE SKYWALKER TO THE DARK SIDE,
AND THEN SOUGHT TO RESCUE HIS
SON.
AS A HUMBLE PRIEST HE HAS
STRIVED TO REBUILD AN
AFRICANVILLE LANGUAGE IN THE ERA
OF APAR TIED, AND HE HAS DRIVE
MS. DAISY IN THE DAYS OF J
CROWE.
AS THE NOBLE JOVI JEFER,
OF PRINCE, HE HAS RULED AS KING
OF ZAMUNDA.
AND AT NLE MUFA, FATHER O
SYMBA, HE HAS RULED AS KING OF
THE JUNGLE.
THE NATIONAL MEDAL OF ARTS
LIFETIME AWARDS FROM BOT THE
SCREEN ACTORS BUILD AND THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF MOTION
PICTURE ARTS A IENCES, A
TONY AWARD FOR LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT SOON TO COME, AND
THAT VOICE, THAT VOICE RESONANT
AND DEEP AND UTTERLY
UNMISTAKABLE, ALL THIS, AFTER
OVERCOMING A SEVERE STUTTER AS A
CHILD, WHICH FOR YEARS OFTEN
LEFT HIM MUTE.
BORN IN RURAL MISSISSIPPI,
RAISED IN MICHAN, INITIALLY A
PREMED IN COLLEGE, AN AY
VETERAN, HE WAS A NIGHT JANITOR
IN OFF-BROADWAY THEATERS BEFORE
EMERGING AS ONE OF AMERICA'S
MOST ACCOMPLISHED AND ADMIRED
ACTORS ON BOTH STAGE AND REEN.
W.
[APPLAUSE]
>> AN ACTOR OF IMNINTABLE POWER
WHO'S ROLES BESPEAK HIS SINGULA
RESOURCES.
WHEN HE, AROUND UNTAISHED TALE
DELIVERS, THERE'S NO ANY DOUBT
WITH WHOM T FORCE IS.
JAMES EARL JONES, DOCTOR OF
ARTS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> HAVING ALREADY WELCOMED AN
ICONICCE AND A COMPOSURE OF
COMPACT DISC LAND OF THE JEDI
FAR, FAR WAY, TODAY ON THE 40th
ANNIVERSARY OF THE OPENING OF
"STAR WA" WE RECOGNIZE ONE OF
THE MOST ACCOMPLHED PEOPLE
EVER TO HAVE CELRATED A
STAR-WARS THEMED BAR MITZVAH.
TESTIMONY WAS CLEAR FROM
CHILDHD THAT THE FORCE IS
EVEN BEFORE HE TURNED 13, HE
CREATED ZU NET A HOME COUTERTWO
FATHER'S DENTAL OFFICE IN NEW
YORK.
HE WASN'T YOUR ORDINARY
TEENAGER.
HE WAS FASCINATED BY ANCIENT
GREEK AND LATIN.
HE WAS THE PRIDE OF HIS SCHOOL'S
FENCING TEAM.
BUT BEYON THAT, THERE WAS HIS
EYE-OPENING ABILITY TO CODE.
THAT AND HIS UNCANNY FORESIGHT
IN SEEING THAT PEOPLE WANTED
COMPUTERS TO CONNECT THEM NOT
JUST WITH OTHER COMPUTERS, BUT
WITH OTHER PEOPLE.
HE CAME TO HARVARD AS A FRESHMAN
NEARLY 15 YEARS AGO IN THE FALL
OF 2002.
AS A SOPHOMORE, HE MOVED INTO
KIRKLAND HOUSE.
THERE HE LAUNCHED THE FORERUNNER
OF WHAT HAS GWN INTO THE MOST
FAR-REACHING SOCIAL NETWORK ON
THE PLANET.
HE LEFT COLLEGE FOR SILICON
VALLEY.
HE DPPED "THE" FROM FACEBOOK.
HE COMBINED HIS TECHNICAL
PROWESS, HIS ENTREPRENEURIAL
SAVVY, AND HIS INSTINCTS ABOUT
SOCIAL BEHAVIOR TO BUILD
FABOOK INTO A GLOBAL
ENOMENON, SOMEG THAT IS
NOW USED BY 1.94 BILLION PEOPLE
WORLDWIDE ON A REGULAR BASIS.
IT IS WITH THE GATEST OF
PRIDE, HAVING CONFIRMED THAT HIS
BILLS ARE FULLY PAID, THAT WE
LCOME BACK MARK ZUCKERBERG TO
AT LAST EARN HIS HARVARD DEGREE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> REMARKABLY YOUNG FOR THIS
CROWD, AND YET AMAZINGLY
>> GENITOR, MOXIMUS, LIBRE, FROM
A WHITE BOARD IN KIRKLAND HOUSE
TO ONE HACK AWAY, HE HAS FORGED
A TRANSRMATION THROUGH THE
POWER OF CONNECTN AND SET HIS
SIGHTS ON HOW BOLD NEW IDEAS CAN
SERVE THE WORLD.
MARKEL LOT ZUCKERBERG, DOCTOR OF
LAWS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> HIS FIRST HARVARD DEGREE,
DOCTOR OF LAW.
>> IN THE NAME OF THIS SOCIETY
OF SCHOLARS, I DECLARE THAT
THESE PERSONS ARE ENTITLED TO
THE RIGHTS AND PRIVILEGES
PENINGO THEIR SEVERAL
DEGREES, AND THAT THEIR NAMES
ARE TO BE FOREVER BORN ON ITS
ROLL OF HONORARY MEMBERS.
>> DEGREE CANDIDATES AND THEIR
GUESTS AND ALL ALUMNI ARE WARMLY
INVITED TO ATTEND THE AFTERNOON
SESSION OF COMMEEMENT DAY
EXERCISES UNDER THE DIRECTION OF
THE HARVARD ALUMNI ASSOCIATION.
N
AT 1:45 P.M., AND THE EXERCISES
COMMENCEMENT SPEAKERS WILL BE
MR. MARKEL LOT ZUCKERBERG AND
THE PRESIDENT OF HARVARD
UNIVERSITY.
NOW THE COMMENCEMENT CHOIR
DIRECTOR WILL LEAD US IN THE
SINGING OF THE COMMENCEMENT
HYMN.
FOLLOWING THE HYMN, THE PUSEY
WILL PRONOUNCE THE NEDICTION.
THE COMMENCEMENT EXERCISES THEN
BEING ENDED, THE SHERIFF OF
MIDDLESEX COUNTLY WILL DECLARE
THE MEETING ADJOURNED.
AUDIENCE
SEATED UIL THE PRESIDENT AND
FELLOWS AND THEIR GUESTS HAVE
WITHDRAWN FROM THE PLATFORM.
DES OMNIUM CREATOR
RERUM MUNDI MODERATOR
CRESCAT CUIUS ENDATOR
NOSTRA UNIVERSITAS
NTEGRI SINT CURATORES ERUDITI
PROFESSORES
LARGIANTUR DONATORES BENE
PARTAS COPIAS
SIC D CIVITAS MANEBIT
CLARUM LUMEN HIC LUCEBIT
LUCE ANGULOS REPLEBIT
FUGERIT OBSCURITAS
ERROR TERRITUS LABIT
VIRTUS VIVIDA VALEBIT
ET INSIGNIOR FLOREBIT
NOSTRA UNIVERSITAS
>> LIFE IS SHORT AND TIME IS
FILLED WITH SWIFT TRANSITION.
THUS WE DO NOT HAVE MUCH TIME TO
GLADDEN THE HEARTS OF THOSE WHO
TRAVEL ALONG LIFE'S JOURNEY WITH
US.
THUS, BE SWIFT TO LOVE.
MAKE HASTE TO BE KI.
BE QUICK TO COMPLIMENT AND SLOW
TO CRITICIZE, ANDEMEMBEREVER
SPEAK A WORD OF JUDGMENT WITHOUT
FIRST SPEAKING A WORD OF GRACE.
AND IF WE DO THESE THINGS, WE
WILL BEGIN TO PROXIMATE WHAT IT
MEANS TOO JUSTICE, TO LOVE
MERCY, AND TO WALK HUMBLY BEFORE
OUR GOD.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY, CLASS OF
2017, WE SAY TO YOU ON THIS DAY,
MAY THE FOR BE WITH U.
[APPLAUSE]
>> AND HERE COMES THE HIGH
SHERIFF OF MIDDLESEX COUNTY TO
END THE CEREMONY.
>> AS THE HIGH SHERIFF OF
MIDDLESEX COUNTY, I DECLARE THAT
THE MEETING WILL BEADJOURNED!
AND NOW THE BELLS.
>> THE BELLS FROM ACRS
CAMBRIDGE, ALL THE WAY TO THE 17
WONDERFUL BELLS OF THE LOWELL
TOWER BELL TOWER THAT WILL
ACTUALLY BE SILENT FOR THE NEXT
AND A WONDERFUL, WONDERFUL TION.
COMMENCEMENT.
>> WONDERFUL COMNCEMENT
DESPITE THE WEATHER.
THE RECESSION BEGINS.
MEMBERS OF THE COURSE AND THE
OVERSEERS AND THE DEAN AND THE
FACULTY WILL SLOWLYOME
OFFSTAGE, RETREAT FOR A LITTLE
BITE OF LUNCH AND THEN RETURN
FOR THE AFTERNOON EXERCISES.
>> I TNK SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT OUR COMMENCEMENT SPEAKER
SAID ARE WORTH REMEMBERING AT
THIS POINT.
I GO BACK TO THE LATINATION,
SAID EVEN NOW WE STAND NOT
AT THE END OF TH STORY, THAT
WORK SEEMS UNFINISHED, JU AS
VIRGIL'S WAS UNFINISHED AND W
NEED TO GO AND FINISH OUR LIVES.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
AND THEN WE HAD THAT WONDERFUL
ADDRESS BY THE YOUNG
UNDERGRADUE WHO HAD BEGUN H
SIX-YEAR-OLD LIFE IN FST GRADE
AT THE TIME OF THE BOMBING THE
WORLD TRADE CENTER.
>> THERE'S DAME JUDI DENCH AND
WALTER MASSEY, BOTH HEADING OFF
WITH THEIR HONORARY DEGREE.
>> SHE SAID AS WE WALK THROUGH
THESE GATES, LET'S COSE OUR
WEAPONS WISELY, HOPE AND COURAGE
AND LOVE IN THE FACE OF FEAR.
AND WHAT WONDERFUL EXAMPLES
THESE HONORANDS HAVE GIVEN THESE
GRADUATES TODAY, WHETHER THEY'RE
FROM THE CLASS OF 2017 OR IN T
GRADUA SCHOOLS.
AND THE GRADUATE
THE DIVITY SCHOOL URGING
PEOPLE TO ENTER INTO THIS MESSY
AND TRAGIC AND LOVELY WORLD AND
MAKE A FFERENCE.
>> AND LET'S NOT FORG, AS WE
HEAD OFF TO REMEMBER TO
OURSELVESE A LITTLE
BEWILDERED.
>> BE A LITTLE BEWILDERED.
>> WE LIVE IN INTERTING TIMES,
AND WE CAN EACH OF US MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE, LET'S SUPPORT ALL OF
THESE NEW GRADUATES WHO ARE
GOING TO HAVE SUCH A PROFOUND
IMPACT ON THE WORLD, ESPECIALLY
WHEN THEY APPROACH IT WITH SOME
CURIOSITY AND BEWILDER NY.
>> AND YOUR WORK IN THE CENTER
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL UDIES,
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
>> WELL, IS A WONDERFUL
COMMUNITY WE ARE IN, ANDE'RE
SOTUNATE TO BE HERE.
>> IT CERTAINLY IS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU AT HOME, GOODBYE.